Hey everyone, my name is Stella.
大家好，我叫斯特拉。
Fear not though, because if you haven't already deciphered from my accent, I'm not from New Jersey, but from Australia.
不过，不要害怕，因为如果你还没有听出我的口音，我不是来自新泽西州，而是来自澳大利亚。
My relationship with this comfort show of mine is ever-evolving and continues to evolve thanks to this podcast.
我与这个安慰节目的关系不断发展，并且由于这个播客而继续发展。
Now as a Stella myself, there's no greater example of my ever-evolving relationship with this show than in the season of Stella.
现在，作为《Stella》的一员，没有比《Stella》这一季更能体现我与这部剧不断发展的关系的例子了。
You know, Jimmy would scream at the TV.
你知道，吉米会对着电视尖叫。
She's not right for you, mate.
她不适合你，伙计。
I remember thinking that the right person shouldn't make love this hard.
我记得我当时想，对的人不应该让爱变得如此艰难。
Love isn't about expecting someone to conform to your vision of the future.
爱不是期望某人符合你对未来的愿景。
It's about writing a narrative together.
这是关于一起写一个叙述。
But motherhood has given me a far more empathetic perspective of Stella.
但母亲身份让我对斯特拉有了更加同理心的看法。
I now see that Stella was rightfully guarded.
我现在看到斯特拉受到了正当的保护。
As a mum, every decision you make carries consequences beyond yourself.
作为一名母亲，您做出的每一个决定都会带来超出您自身范围的后果。
And Stella knew that her daughter would wear the burden of her mistakes if Ted was a massive one.
斯特拉知道，如果特德是个大人物，她的女儿就会为她所犯的错误承担责任。
Her constant boundary setting, which teenage me saw as emotional distance and this rigidity, I now see as necessary protection.
她不断设定的界限，在我十几岁的时候认为是情感上的距离和这种僵化，现在我认为是必要的保护。
Did Stella feel that her daughter would never be truly prioritised because Ted was anchored in a the way to this juvenile New York City kind of life.
斯特拉是否觉得她的女儿永远不会被真正优先考虑，因为泰德已经过着纽约市的青少年生活。
So I want to thank you so much for this surprisingly therapeutic lens.
因此，我非常感谢您提供这款令人惊奇的治疗镜片。
All the best, everyone.
祝大家一切顺利。
And now, back to the show.
现在，回到节目。
I'm alone, don't be sued.
我一个人，别被骂。
You know York City, when I see you.
当我见到你时，你就知道约克市。
Please permit me to tell you everything in New York City.
请允许我告诉你纽约市的一切。
Well, talk about knowing the assignments.
好吧，谈谈了解作业。
that really helped us, really helped T.S.
这真的帮助了我们，真的帮助了 T.S.
up here.
在这里。
Welcome to How We Made Your Mother.
欢迎收看《我们如何成就了你的母亲》。
I'm Josh Radner.
我是乔什·拉德纳。
I'm here with my friend Craig Thomas.
我和我的朋友克雷格·托马斯在这里。
Hey Josh.
嘿乔什。
Talking about how I met your mother.
谈论我是如何认识你母亲的。
We are barreling through season three.
我们正在快速完成第三季。
This is season three, episode 13, is that right?
这是第三季第 13 集，对吗？
Correct.
正确的。
It's called 10 Sessions.
这就是所谓的 10 次会议。
It's an all-timer.
这是一个全能的。
Wait, hang on, it might be 12.
等等，等一下，可能已经12点了。
Alec, is it 12?
亚历克，现在是 12 点吗？
It's 13, never mind.
已经13了，没关系。
Let's keep going.
我们继续吧。
Question, but we are so excited.
问题，但我们很兴奋。
We're not talking about this episode, just me and Craig, which I just can't bear just talking to him.
我们不是在谈论这一集，只是在谈论我和克雷格，我只是无法忍受只和他说话。
I don't blame you.
我不怪你。
I'm fucking up numbers all the time.
我一直在搞数字。
We are delighted to have the ever delightful Sarah chalk with us today.
我们很高兴今天有永远令人愉快的莎拉粉笔和我们在一起。
Hi, Sarah.
嗨，莎拉。
Hi, guys.
嗨，大家好。
Thank you for being here.
感谢您来到这里。
Thank you so much for having me.
非常感谢你邀请我。
Congratulations on your podcast.
恭喜你的播客。
Colated from Canada.
取自加拿大。
Congratulations on podcast.
恭喜播客。
Josh, that song is beautiful.
乔什，那首歌很美。
Oh, thanks.
哦，谢谢。
Right?
正确的？
It's so good.
太好了。
Josh, I didn't write it for...
乔什，我写这篇文章不是为了...
Josh's music is so good on Barrisom.
Barrison 的 Josh 的音乐非常好。
Go check out Josh's music.
去听一下乔什的音乐。
It's so great.
太棒了。
He has a couple albums out and there's a new one soon to be out, soonish.
他已经发行了几张专辑，而且很快就会发行一张新专辑。
It's all so great.
这一切都太棒了。
Check it out.
一探究竟。
It's the best.
这是最好的。
I'm plugging Josh's music for him so there.
我正在为他插入乔什的音乐。
I wasn't a songwriter, Sarah, when we were working together.
莎拉，当我们一起工作时，我还不是词曲作者。
No. It was a later in life development.
不，这是生命后期的发展。
How did you find it?
你是怎么找到它的？
Oh, it's got another podcast.
哦，还有另一个播客。
But I started writing songs with my friend Ben Lee, who's an Australian songwriter, and I just learned how to play songs and found out I was pretty good at it and loved it, and I've just been making music ever since.
但我开始和我的朋友本·李（Ben Lee）一起写歌，他是一位澳大利亚歌曲作家，我刚刚学会了如何演奏歌曲，发现我非常擅长并且喜欢它，从那时起我就一直在创作音乐。
Anyway, that's our time with Sarah.
无论如何，这是我们和莎拉在一起的时间。
Thanks for coming on.
感谢您的光临。
Thanks, Sarah, thanks for being here.
谢谢莎拉，谢谢你来到这里。
Nice!
好的！
Sarah, we love you.
莎拉，我们爱你。
So thank you for being here.
谢谢你来到这里。
Just to go all the way back, Carter and I, Carter Bays and I co-creator of How Much Mother, our spec script, when we were trying to get hired for a job writing on a sitcom, was a scrub spec script.
回想一下，卡特和我，卡特·贝斯和我共同创作了《妈妈有多好》，我们的规格剧本，当我们试图受聘从事情景喜剧写作工作时，是一个擦洗规格脚本。
I was writing Elliot jokes.
我正在写艾略特笑话。
I was, we were super fans of Scrub's while we were writing for David Lonerman.
我是，当我们为 David Lonerman 写作时，我们都是 Scrub 的超级粉丝。
I'm probably told you this at the time when we had you on the show.
我可能是在你参加节目的时候告诉你的。
This was your first episode on the show.
这是你在节目中的第一集。
It was at a very momentous moment.
那是一个非常重要的时刻。
It was coming right out of the writer's guild strike.
这是作家行会罢工后的结果。
We had Britney Spears in the episode.
布兰妮·斯皮尔斯参与了这一集。
There's a lot to unpack here.
这里有很多东西需要解压。
But just to back it way up, super fans of you, super fans of Scrub's The Great Bill Lawrence was so nice to share you with us while you were still on Scrub's.
但只是为了支持这一点，你的超级粉丝，Scrub 的超级粉丝伟大的比尔·劳伦斯（The Great Bill Lawrence）非常高兴在你还在 Scrub 的时候与我们分享你的经历。
I believe you brought the same lab coat from scrubs to how I met your mother and wore it on the show.
我相信你带了我见到你母亲时穿的那件实验服，并在节目中穿着它。
I think that might be true unless I'm making that up.
我认为这可能是真的，除非我编造的。
You were like, why are these guys making me play a doctor again?
你想，为什么这些人又让我扮演医生？
I can't cheat on my old job as a doctor with a new, totally new profession.
我不能放弃我作为一名医生的旧工作，从事新的、全新的职业。
But you were so nice to come do this and do double duty two shows at once coming out of the strike.
但你很高兴能来参加这个活动，并在罢工后同时进行两场演出。
So just first off, thank you for doing this show with us.
首先，感谢您与我们一起做这个节目。
Oh my God, are you kidding me?
天哪，你在开玩笑吗？
Thank you so much for having me.
非常感谢你邀请我。
It remains one of my favorite experiences of my career.
这仍然是我职业生涯中最喜欢的经历之一。
It was so fun.
太有趣了。
You guys could not have been more welcoming.
你们真是太热情了。
It was like the most warm, the water's warm, get in, you know, experience.
这就像最温暖的，水是温暖的，进入，你知道，体验。
And like, how many episodes did you do that season?
比如，你那个赛季拍了多少集？
Do you remember?
你是否记得？
It was several.
有好几个。
I feel like it was like, maybe I want to say a few, that season and a few the next.
我觉得，也许我想说一些，那个赛季和下一个赛季。
Yeah, like the next season there was a lot of, they wouldn't feel like you came in like deep into, you had one episode that was like a little deeper in the show.
是的，就像下一季有很多，他们不会觉得你深入其中，你有一集在节目中有点深入。
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, there was one little hello way later in the series that was a great moment and very much She's getting here as fast as she does.
是啊，是啊，是啊，是啊，在这个系列的后面有一个小小的问候，那是一个伟大的时刻，而且她很快就到达了这里。
Yes.
是的。
That was one of the great moment one of the great lands on the great Great scene.
那是伟大场景中伟大土地之一的伟大时刻之一。
So you were so nice to come back Sarah.
莎拉，你回来真是太好了。
I gotta say We Jordan and my wife and I went to our dear friends Elian and Neema got married in Mexico last month and Neema grew up in Tehran until he was either 13 or 15 I think he was 15 and he came to to Canada.
我得说，我们乔丹和我的妻子和我去了我们亲爱的朋友埃利安和尼玛上个月在墨西哥结婚了，尼玛在德黑兰长大，直到他 13 或 15 岁，我想他 15 岁，他来到了加拿大。
He moved to Toronto with his family when they left Iran and he didn't speak any English and he learned to speak English from scrubs and how I met your mother.
当他们离开伊朗时，他和家人搬到了多伦多，他不会说任何英语，他是从实习生和我如何认识你母亲那里学会说英语的。
Oh my god.
我的天啊。
Scrubs was his number one.
斯克鲁斯是他的第一。
He said to this day, if he sees scrubs like playing through a window, he can say what episode it is.
直到今天，他说，如果他透过窗户看到像在玩耍的磨砂膏，他就能说出那是哪一集。
He knows the show so well from like a still, you know how there's like how many people can do that?
他对这部剧非常了解，就像剧照一样，你知道有多少人能做到这一点吗？
Like you'll say, what outfit is this episode and they'll know he's like that with scrubs but I so you know I'm sure he'd be delighted that we're talking today.
就像你会说的，这一集穿什么衣服，他们会知道他穿着磨砂服，但我相信他会很高兴我们今天谈话。
That is really cool that is so cool yeah it's um it's how I met your mother you know is one of the things that like it's crazy the the many lives of how I met your mother like people obviously and you guys know this more than anyone are just like the new generation of teenagers now are obsessed with it and tuning in and binging the whole thing And I have people coming up to me all the time, like screaming at me with such emotion and passion in the street about leaving Ted at the entree.
这真的很酷，太酷了，是的，嗯，这就是我遇见你母亲的方式，你知道，这就是疯狂的事情之一，我和你母亲的相遇就像人们的许多生活一样，你们比任何人都更了解这一点，就像现在新一代的青少年沉迷于它，收听并沉迷于整个事情一样，我一直有人来找我，就像在街上带着如此情感和热情对我尖叫，因为要把特德留在主菜上。
Oh, no.
哦，不。
I think great to be blamed for something your character did.
我认为因为你的角色所做的事情而受到指责是件好事。
I'm so sorry.
我很抱歉。
You have a nice person in the world and we've ruined everything.
你在世界上有一个好人，我们却毁了一切。
I'm sorry.
对不起。
We love you.
我们爱你。
I hope you know that.
我希望你知道这一点。
No, but in all seriousness, like people are so excited and complimentary of the show and you know my niece who is 23 was she's in Ireland trying to be a doctor and someone was like you know and didn't know the relationship between her and I and was like you look exactly like Stella from how I met your mother yeah it was crazy it's crazy global impact of scrubs and How much money like these things we did right in our late 20s early 30s that in the moment of making them There was no way we could have known what the future was that there'd be that Josh could say his friend learned English watching you on scrubs These are these are inconceivable thoughts for our little brains when we were 30 doing these shows, right?
不，但说实话，人们对这个节目非常兴奋和称赞，你知道我 23 岁的侄女正在爱尔兰尝试成为一名医生，有人就像你知道的那样，不知道我和她之间的关系，就像我和你母亲见面时的斯特拉一样，是的，这太疯狂了，磨砂膏对全球产生了疯狂的影响，像我们在 20 岁末 30 岁出头做的这些事情在制作它们的那一刻就赚了多少钱我们不可能知道未来会怎样，乔什会说他的朋友看着你穿着手术服学会了英语。当我们 30 岁做这些节目时，这些对于我们的小大脑来说是不可思议的想法，对吧？
Like it's it's trippy, isn't it?
就像它很迷幻，不是吗？
Hemium have a very similar band like place in the we're in the same graduating class of sitcoms and I think the both shows have super fans.
Hemium 有一个非常相似的乐队，就像我们在同一届情景喜剧毕业班一样，我认为这两部剧都有超级粉丝。
When you hear that stuff, does it blow your mind?
当你听到这些东西时，是否让你大吃一惊？
Yeah, it does.
是的，确实如此。
It blows our mind and I agree with you.
这让我们大吃一惊，我同意你的观点。
I think they're very much of a similar graduating class, both in like the fact that they have lived on and gotten to kind of have new generations fall in love with them, but also that they were kind of both in their own way doing super different things in comedy at that time, things that other shows weren't doing.
我认为他们是非常相似的毕业生，既因为他们一直生活下去并让新一代人爱上了他们，而且他们都以自己的方式在喜剧中做了当时其他节目没有做的超级不同的事情。
Yeah, they kind of both invented their own comedic vocabulary, like, in totally different ways.
是的，他们都以完全不同的方式发明了自己的喜剧词汇。
But emotional, they were emos at comps.
但情绪激动，他们在比赛中表现得很情绪化。
And that's why we liked Scrub.
这就是我们喜欢 Scrub 的原因。
That's why we wrote a Scrubs before we ever created How Much Mother.
这就是为什么我们在创作《How Much Mother》之前就写了《Scrubs》。
We wanted to write a show without feeling, because it could make you cry, Scrubs.
我们想写一部没有感情的剧，因为它会让你哭泣，斯科鲁斯。
Congrats on it being back around.
恭喜它回来了。
Like, I want to ask you what it's like to read, we're revisiting our memories of him on a podcast.
就像，我想问你阅读是什么感觉，我们正在播客上重温对他的记忆。
You're actually like, you're going back there.
你实际上就像，你要回到那里。
You're actually back in the 2026 version of Scrubs, which is fascinating.
你实际上回到了 2026 年版本的 Scrubs，这很有趣。
And I want to know more about that.
我想了解更多相关信息。
but we should talk about this episode.
但我们应该谈谈这一集。
Yeah, let's talk about 10 sessions.
是的，我们来谈谈 10 次会议。
Was this, I believe this was written by Carter Basin Craig Thomas, is that right?
我相信这是卡特·巴辛·克雷格·托马斯写的，对吗？
Yeah, this was in the melee and madness of the writer's guild strike ended.
是的，这就是在作家行会罢工的混战和疯狂中结束的。
And then it was like, hey guys, you gotta make nine episodes in 10 and a half weeks.
然后就好像，嘿伙计们，你们必须在 10 周半的时间里拍出 9 集。
So we wrote this in a hurry.
所以我们就匆匆写下了这篇文章。
And all of a sudden two things needed to happen.
突然间有两件事需要发生。
We needed to figure out how we were gonna write a part for Britney Spears who had reached out.
我们需要弄清楚如何为伸出援手的布兰妮·斯皮尔斯写一个角色。
Her people wanted her to do our show.
她的人民希望她来做我们的节目。
And two, we needed to cast this hugely important role of Stella in a hurry.
第二，我们需要尽快选拔斯特拉这个极其重要的角色。
But we were all on strike and there was no way to get ahead of it.
但我们都在罢工，没有办法提前。
So we called you super last minute as I recall because we were just scrambling out of the strike.
所以我记得我们在最后一刻给你打电话，因为我们刚刚摆脱罢工。
It's astonishing.
真是令人惊讶。
It all came together.
这一切都聚集在一起。
What is your memory of like, and did it feel weird to be getting an offer to come do like an arc on another show while you were on a show?
你的记忆是怎样的？当你在演出的时候，收到另一个节目的邀请，像弧线一样，感觉很奇怪吗？
Like, what's your memory of us asking you in this completely last minute insane way to do this?
比如，你对我们在最后一刻以这种完全疯狂的方式要求你做这件事有什么记忆？
Okay.
好的。
I loved the show.
我喜欢这个节目。
I watched it.
我看了。
I loved it.
我喜欢它。
And I was actually sitting at Pinkberry with Nicole Sullivan.
事实上，我和 Nicole Sullivan 坐在 Pinkberry 餐厅。
And we were having first yogurt.
我们先喝了酸奶。
And I remember getting a call.
我记得接到电话。
And my memory of it is that it wasn't an arc at the time.
我的记忆是，当时它还不是弧线。
It was that week.
就是那一周。
It was the call that I got.
这是我接到的电话。
It was come to this episode, 10 sessions.
到了这一集，一共10集。
And it was a Tuesday.
那是一个星期二。
And obviously you guys have like a Monday to Friday schedule.
显然你们有周一到周五的日程安排。
It was already the Tuesday.
已经是星期二了。
So my recollection was that someone else is doing the part, had fallen out of the part.
所以我的记忆是其他人正在做这个角色，但已经退出了这个角色。
I got a call on the Tuesday.
我周二接到电话。
It was like, can you come right now?
就像，你现在可以来吗？
like just drive over here.
就像开车来这里一样。
And I was like, yeah, great.
我当时想，是的，太棒了。
I'm in.
我进来了
So I drove over you.
所以我就开车从你身上碾过去了。
I completely forget what that was, by the way.
顺便说一句，我完全忘记那是什么了。
I'm going to have to text side text Pam Friman to remind me because I'm having an old man moment because that's astonishing.
我得给帕姆·弗里曼发短信提醒我，因为我正经历一个老人时刻，因为这太令人惊讶了。
Okay, keep going.
好吧，继续。
Yeah.
是的。
I remember who it was.
我记得是谁。
And so we shouldn't talk about it.
所以我们不应该谈论它。
And I wrote you this little ditty to send you in New York City.
我给你写了这首小曲，寄给你在纽约市。
We'll be right back.
我们马上回来。
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the Hyper-Fixed Podcast.
大家好，我是 Alex Goldman，Hyper-Fixed 播客的主持人。
Each week, we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周，我们都会收集听众的问题并尝试为他们解决。
Problems like, I'm 30 and I'm scared to drive in New York.
诸如此类的问题，我已经 30 岁了，我害怕在纽约开车。
Or why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
或者为什么我倒车时无法调节汽车音响的音量？
We also solve non-car-related problems.
我们还解决与汽车无关的问题。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that cause that problem in the first place.
如果您遇到问题，我们不仅会修复它，还会首先暴露导致该问题的隐藏系统。
That's the Hyper-Fixed Podcast from Radiotopia.
这是来自 Radiotopia 的 Hyper-Fixed 播客。
at wherever you find podcasts or at hyperfixedpod.com.
无论您在哪里找到播客或在 hyperfixedpod.com 上。
So then I drove over to you guys and you guys gave me the script and we were, you guys were already in rehearsal for it.
然后我开车去找你们，你们给了我剧本，我们，你们已经在排练了。
So we rehearsed and it was immediately fun.
所以我们排练了一下，立刻就很有趣。
Like it was one of those things where, you know, I loved like as an actor, the model that you guys used of like rehearsing and then the network run through and then shooting on the other few days of the week.
就像这是其中一件事，你知道，我喜欢像演员一样，你们使用的模式，比如排练，然后网络运行，然后在一周的其他几天拍摄。
what I feel like is you had the best of both worlds of it, you got the feeling of doing, you know, in front of an audience just because you had the network run through and it felt like you're doing a mini play.
我的感觉是，你两全其美，你有一种在观众面前表演的感觉，你知道，只是因为你有网络运行，感觉就像你在做一部迷你剧。
A little play.
玩一点儿。
And that was just like, was something super unique that like most shows don't get to do.
这就像是一些超级独特的事情，就像大多数节目无法做到的那样。
And then also had the benefit of the way you shot it so that you could have more flexibility in terms of getting like cool things like the two minute date.
然后你的拍摄方式也有好处，这样你就可以更灵活地完成像两分钟约会这样很酷的事情。
And so yeah, so I get the call, is it Pinkberry?
是的，所以我接到电话，是 Pinkberry 吗？
Do you remember you guys?
你们还记得你们吗？
And then that was the week before we went back to shooting scrubs.
那是我们重新开始拍摄工作服的前一周。
So that week I was not doing double duty, but then they called and said, we never would have gotten you if that wasn't true.
所以那周我没有双重职责，但后来他们打电话说，如果不是真的，我们永远不会找到你。
That's the only reason we got you is that they didn't grab.
这就是我们抓住你的唯一原因是他们没有抓住。
There was a minute before they started to back up.
有一分钟后他们才开始倒退。
So crazy.
太疯狂了。
It's been a fun time to back up.
这是一个有趣的备份时间。
And then, and then after we did that episode, you guys had said, can you come back and do more?
然后，在我们拍完那集之后，你们说，你们能回来做更多吗？
And I said, I would love to.
我说，我很愿意。
And then we asked Bill Lawrence and he said, yeah, let's make it work.
然后我们问比尔劳伦斯，他说，是的，让我们让它发挥作用。
And so I remember I would wake up and come to you guys first and get into her makeup at like five and start shooting at like seven.
所以我记得我会醒来，先到你们那里，五点左右化妆，七点左右开始拍摄。
and then I shoot to like 11.30 and then I drive to scrubs.
然后我会赶到 11.30 左右，然后我开车去灌木丛。
Same lab coat, you're right, it was the same one.
同样的实验服，你是对的，是同一件。
Easily transferable.
易于转移。
And then shoot, and so I just remember like, I didn't sleep a ton, but I loved it.
然后拍摄，所以我只记得，我睡不着，但我喜欢它。
It was really fun.
真的很有趣。
It reminds me there's a famous story about crazy and Cynthia Nixon when she was a teenager.
这让我想起了一个关于疯子和辛西娅·尼克松青少年时期的著名故事。
She was in two Broadway shows at once.
她同时参加了两场百老汇演出。
Do you guys know this?
你们知道这个吗？
No.
不。
She was in Hurley Burley and Tom Stoppard's The Real Thing, but she was in the first act of one of them and the second act of the other one.
她曾出演过赫尔利·伯利和汤姆·斯托帕德的《真实之物》，但她只出演了其中一个的第一幕和另一个的第二幕。
so she would run like two blocks through an alley and join this other cast.
所以她会跑过两个街区，穿过一条小巷，加入其他演员的行列。
And she only, I think, took one curtain call.
我认为她只谢幕了一次。
But they made a rule that you can't do that anymore.
但他们制定了一条规则，你不能再这样做了。
I actually talked to her at this play because I asked her about it.
事实上，我在这部剧中和她交谈过，因为我问过她这件事。
So they made a rule in Actors Act, but you can't do that anymore.
所以他们在《演员法》中制定了一条规则，但你不能再这样做了。
And it's like the Cynthia Nixon clause.
这就像辛西娅·尼克松条款。
It's the Nixon clause, you're not allowed.
这是尼克松条款，你不被允许。
But that's what you were doing.
但这就是你所做的。
You were the Cynthia Nixon of the Primetime sitcoms.
你是黄金时段情景喜剧中的辛西娅·尼克松。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
I do remember reversing into a pillar in the parking garage, a parquet as we call it, Canada, and thinking like, a parquet, there it is.
我确实记得倒车到停车场的一根柱子上，我们称之为“加拿大”的镶木地板，然后想，镶木地板就在那里。
Slow down, it'll be fine when you get there.
慢点，到了就没事了。
Ooh.
哦。
Yeah.
是的。
Bill Lawrence was very nice to let, to say yes to this, by the way.
顺便说一下，比尔·劳伦斯非常乐意接受这一点。
I want to give him a big shout out.
我想对他大声喊叫。
He could have easily said like, no, she's one of the stars of my show.
他本可以轻松地说，不，她是我节目的明星之一。
You can't have her.
你不能拥有她。
And I think we knew in the back of our head that we wanted more of you and that we were going to ask you back, but we didn't want to frighten anyone.
我想我们内心深处知道我们想要更多的你，我们会要求你回来，但我们不想吓到任何人。
So we said it's a one off, but really we knew it was more.
所以我们说这是一次性的，但实际上我们知道这不仅仅是一次。
I completely forget who it was going to be first.
我完全忘记了第一个会是谁。
I get my recollection is we were told, put this other person on as a love interest.
我记得有人告诉我们，把这个人当作爱情对象。
I mean, you can't say it, right?
我的意思是，你不能说出来，对吧？
You can't say what your memory is of it.
你无法说出你对它的记忆。
It would be too awkward.
那就太尴尬了。
Question mark.
问号。
I can after we cut.
剪完之后我就可以了
I'll tell you guys.
我会告诉你们。
I remember.
我记得。
We'll have to do it later, because I'm really forgetting it.
我们得稍后再做，因为我真的忘记了。
Wait, was the person fired or what happened?
等等，这个人是被解雇了还是发生了什么？
Not, that wasn't information that I was pretty to, but I don't think so.
不，这不是我喜欢的信息，但我不这么认为。
I am shocked that I can't remember this.
我很震惊，我竟然不记得这个了。
But it's a portrait of how crazy that time was that I can't remember what this was.
但这是那段时光的写照，我不记得那段时光是多么疯狂。
I'm sure it was like, all right, we'll get to it.
我确信这就像，好吧，我们会成功的。
We'll go off my camera.
我们会关掉我的相机。
Do you know what's so great though, Sarah?
莎拉，你知道什么是伟大的吗？
Like, I love when I can be the solution to a problem.
就像，我喜欢我能解决问题。
Like, when they get, like can't cast something and then I step in and can do it.
就像，当他们得到时，就像无法投射某些东西，然后我介入并可以做到这一点。
Like, there's something actually great about that position because you're like, you're kind of just competing against yourself.
就像，这个职位实际上有一些很棒的东西，因为你就像，你只是在与自己竞争。
You're like, you're actually become the hero.
你就像，你实际上成为了英雄。
You just parachute in and you're a hero.
你只要跳伞，你就是英雄。
And I remember the moment you started reading, I just felt like you were in the world understood the tone and you just felt like you had always kind of been there and also this strangeness of that was such a strange week because Britney Spears was there that first week.
我记得你开始阅读的那一刻，我只是觉得你在这个世界上理解了语气，你只是觉得你一直在那里，而且这种奇怪的一周是如此奇怪，因为布兰妮·斯皮尔斯第一周就在那里。
It's the weirdest moment.
这是最奇怪的时刻。
It was so weird.
太奇怪了。
But before we go on to the week, I just want to say when did this episode air because we like to ground this?
但在我们继续本周之前，我只想说这一集什么时候播出，因为我们喜欢将其搁置？
When did this episode air?
这集什么时候播出的？
This was on March 24th, 2008.
这是2008年3月24日。
Okay, and like, so this episode, how would you describe this?
好的，那么这一集，你会如何描述这一点？
Sarah, do you want to describe this?
莎拉，你想描述一下这个吗？
Did you re-watch the episode, by the way?
顺便问一下，你重看了这一集吗？
I did re-watch the episode and it was so fun to watch.
我确实重新观看了这一集，看起来很有趣。
And it's like, it kind of always blows my mind.
就好像，它总是让我大吃一惊。
Do you guys have this experience when you're re-watching?
大家重看的时候有这样的经历吗？
Just like how much is jammed into?
就像塞了多少一样？
21 minutes, 21.30, yes, it's.
21 分钟，21.30，是的，就是这样。
Because you'd have 15, 20 second scenes that are like really, they're like full scenes.
因为你会有 15、20 秒的场景，就像真的一样，它们就像完整的场景。
They're like, there's a beginning, middle, and end to the 20 seconds, you know?
他们就像，这 20 秒有一个开始、中间和结束，你知道吗？
Yeah, yeah, totally.
是的，是的，完全如此。
And there's so much, there's so much that was jammed in.
还有那么多，有那么多被塞进去的东西。
And I actually got to watch like a couple more episodes after that and it was so fun.
之后我实际上又看了几集，非常有趣。
Are you guys having the best time just rewatching and revisiting all those memories?
你们是否在重温和重温所有这些回忆中度过了最美好的时光？
It's been lovely.
真是太可爱了。
It's been incredible.
这太不可思议了。
Yeah.
是的。
Had watched it that much in a long, long time.
看了好久好久了。
Do you feel, I'm having this experience like, It's impossible to know what show you're on while you're on it in a weird way, like you know that it's working because you keep getting renewed and you know that people are approaching you and they seem to like it, but it's very hard in the moment to get a sense of what the show is and what your role is and how, there's no way to know, just like the narrator of this show, you need some distance from the thing to know what you were a part of, and I feel like I'm having a new appreciation that I was a part of something really special and a big part of really helping it be that.
你是否觉得，我有这样的经历，就像你以一种奇怪的方式知道你在看什么节目一样，就像你知道它正在起作用，因为你不断更新，你知道人们正在接近你，他们似乎喜欢它，但目前很难了解这个节目是什么，你的角色是什么以及如何，没有办法知道，就像这个节目的叙述者一样，你需要与要了解的事物保持一定的距离你曾经参与过什么，我觉得我有了新的认识，我是一个非常特别的事情的一部分，并且是真正帮助它实现这一点的重要组成部分。
Like, because I was very hard on myself in the first draft of my version of this show, you know?
就像，因为我在这个节目的初稿中对自己非常严格，你知道吗？
And, but I do remember, I do remember when we did the two minute date feeling like this is a great moment of TV.
而且，但我确实记得，我确实记得当我们进行两分钟的约会时，感觉这是电视上的一个伟大时刻。
Like this is really cool.
像这样真的很酷。
And I also felt, and we'll get to, we'll talk about it more, but I also felt like you and I were asked to like, do some extreme sport together.
我也觉得，我们会更多地谈论它，但我也觉得你和我被要求一起做一些极限运动。
Like the actor version of like, we were like bungee jumping or jumping out of an airplane together.
就像演员版的《喜欢》一样，我们一起蹦极或者从飞机上跳下来。
And I really like, to mix metaphors, like I really trusted my dance partner.
我真的很喜欢混合比喻，就像我真的信任我的舞伴一样。
Like I remember feeling like, and we only did I think three takes.
就像我记得的感觉一样，我们只考虑了三遍。
Okay, that was my memory too.
好吧，那也是我的记忆。
And then I was re-watching and I wanted to ask you guys that like, how many takes did we do?
然后我重新观看，我想问你们，我们拍了多少遍？
Because it was so fun to get to do a one or like that.
因为做这样的事情真是太有趣了。
Like that doesn't mean to do stuff like that.
像那样并不意味着做那样的事情。
Yeah, I think we did three takes.
是的，我想我们拍了三遍。
And I think it was take two and I bet you for I'm in one to remember.
我想这需要两遍，我敢打赌，我一定会记住这一点。
This is my memory, I think it was three takes, and it was just electric to watch, and the crew racing around to make things fit in play.
这是我的记忆，我想这是三遍，观看起来很刺激，工作人员忙着让事情适合比赛。
It was the most showbiz, like Muppet movie, like Peewee's big adventure, like chase scene through the studio ladder.
这是最演艺圈的，就像布偶电影，就像皮威的大冒险，就像通过工作室阶梯的追逐场景。
It was like, what do you think Hollywood is gonna be like?
就像，你认为好莱坞会是什么样子？
And it's usually not like that, but it felt like that that day.
通常情况并非如此，但那天却有这样的感觉。
It was like movie magic.
这就像电影魔术一样。
Do you know what else I was struck by, Sarah, was like, how relaxed we looked.
莎拉，你知道我还对什么感到震惊吗，我们看起来多么轻松。
You do.
你做。
You look pretty.
你看起来很漂亮。
But it was like a very high wire act, like it was, you know, the props and the set dressing, they're like, Jenny, I remember like running, like underneath the camera to like set things and then move things and Marshall, Manesh, you know, as Ron G, you know, with the car and they had to move the car, they had to get the car back around the taxi.
但这就像一个非常高的钢丝表演，就像，你知道，道具和布景，他们就像，珍妮，我记得就像跑步，就像在摄像机下面喜欢布景，然后移动东西，马歇尔，马内什，你知道，就像罗恩·G，你知道，用汽车，他们必须移动汽车，他们必须把汽车带回出租车周围。
I would have thought, like if you asked me, when was the two minute date?
我会想，就像你问我，两分钟的约会是什么时候？
I would have put it almost later in the series.
我几乎会把它放在这个系列的后面。
Yeah, like I didn't remember it was like third season and I didn't remember like out of all of the time I spent with you guys in the episodes and I didn't realize this like in the first week because I think you're right Josh I did feel so comfortable and it did feel like a dance and I remember there being I remember feeling Like it was just I mean there was no nerves attached It was just pure fun.
是的，就像我不记得那是第三季，我不记得我在剧集中与你们一起度过的所有时间，我没有像第一周那样意识到这一点，因为我认为你是对的，乔什，我确实感觉很舒服，感觉就像一场舞蹈，我记得在那里，我记得感觉就像这只是我的意思是没有任何紧张，这只是纯粹的乐趣。
Maybe a bit of adrenaline of like okay How can we like get all this in one take on them?
也许有点肾上腺素之类的，好吧，我们怎样才能把所有这些都集中在他们身上呢？
You know out of the corner of your eye when you're doing you can see them take switching over the Italian restaurant to the dessert place and yeah, this is the coolest cause.
你知道，当你这样做的时候，你可以看到他们把意大利餐厅换成了甜点店，是的，这是最酷的原因。
I love that your memory of it is feeling relaxed.
我喜欢你对它的记忆感到轻松。
You both seem, you both, okay, your performance is both amazing, both of you guys are amazing in it.
你们俩看起来，你们俩，好吧，你们的表演都很精彩，你们俩都很棒。
But Sarah, you do seem very relaxed and I love that that's your sense of it because there's nothing relaxing about that week at all.
但是莎拉，你看起来确实很放松，我喜欢你的感觉，因为那一周根本没有放松的地方。
We said, Britney Spears is on, you're doing this while you're shooting scrubs and there's a gigantic league intricate one-shot ending to the episode that has to be done with perfection and last exactly two minutes.
我们说，布兰妮·斯皮尔斯上场了，你在拍摄磨砂膏时就这样做了，这一集有一个巨大的、错综复杂的一次性结局，必须完美地完成，并且持续两分钟。
And you were like, yep.
你就像，是的。
And your memory of it is feeling relaxed.
你对它的记忆感到轻松。
This is why you're amazing in that two minute date.
这就是为什么你在那两分钟的约会中表现出色。
Like I remember that not being like, it didn't feel I remember it felt fun.
就像我记得那不是那样，我不记得那感觉很有趣。
I remember feeling like, Oh my God, it's done.
我记得当时的感觉是，天啊，一切都完成了。
I kind of want to do more.
我有点想做更多。
That was so fun.
那真是太有趣了。
I know.
我知道。
I thought we were going to do more takes and I had the same feeling.
我以为我们会拍更多的镜头，我也有同样的感觉。
I was like, I should, we could do this again.
我当时想，我应该，我们可以再做一次。
But you guys were so good at it.
但你们非常擅长。
We had it, we had it.
我们拥有它，我们拥有它。
I think it was take two and we did like a safety one.
我认为这是需要两次，而我们确实喜欢安全一次。
And it was like really impressive, you guys.
你们真是令人印象深刻。
So we, that could have taken 12 ticks.
所以我们可能需要 12 个刻度。
And I remember it was like a beautiful day, like a beautiful LA day.
我记得那是美好的一天，就像洛杉矶美丽的一天。
I remember like, it was just really fun to be on the New York street.
我记得，在纽约街头真的很有趣。
One of the most beloved scenes in him in history.
这是他历史上最受喜爱的场景之一。
And I also think the crew is like, that is fun for the crew to be asked to do something like that, you know, they're not like off camera, just like eating a yogurt or whatever.
我还认为工作人员会被要求做这样的事情，这对工作人员来说很有趣，你知道，他们不像在镜头外，就像吃酸奶之类的。
Like they're like, they have to be as on it as we were.
就像他们一样，他们必须像我们一样。
This was like Olympic athletes hitting my hitting career.
这就像奥运会运动员冲击我的击球生涯一样。
Let me know where we have athletic event that I've ever been participating, if I'm not like any sport, like all I wanted was a sport.
让我知道我们在哪里有我参加过的体育赛事，如果我不喜欢任何运动，就像我想要的只是一项运动。
But instead, I got in the hat which is the way it goes.
但相反，我戴上了帽子，事情就是这样。
You know, it's funny though, like just to get back to the content of the show, like it's perfect.
你知道，这很有趣，就像回到节目的内容一样，就像它是完美的一样。
It's like such classic Ted Mosby behavior because it's both impressive, it's heroic, it's incredibly sweet, and it's way too much.
这就像泰德·莫斯比（Ted Mosby）的经典行为，因为它既令人印象深刻，又充满英雄气概，又非常甜蜜，而且太过分了。
Like it's so too much to say, it's too much.
好像要说的太多了，太多了。
Like, you just are like, no.
就像，你只是说，不。
But also it's like delightful and it worked, so.
但它也很令人愉快并且有效，所以。
And it really shows like how he really understood that she actually really did like him, but that actually this was her limitation.
这确实表明他如何真正理解她实际上确实喜欢他，但这实际上是她的局限性。
So it was like such a thoughtful, you know, He really saw her and was like, Oh, okay.
所以这就像一个深思熟虑的人，你知道，他真的看到了她，然后说，哦，好吧。
Well, this is what you can do.
嗯，这就是你可以做的。
Yeah.
是的。
I'm working with what I got.
我正在用我所得到的东西工作。
Yeah.
是的。
It's very sweet.
非常甜。
You guys had really good chemistry in it.
你们之间产生了很好的化学反应。
It's very sweet.
非常甜。
We're all rooting for you guys.
我们都支持你们。
And it's nice that it ends with, it's inconclusive, right?
很高兴它结束了，但还没有结论，对吧？
It doesn't, it's not like it works.
不，这不像它的工作原理。
And now they're together.
现在他们在一起了。
It's not quite that, which I like too.
不完全是这样，我也喜欢。
It's felt realistic.
感觉很现实。
She's a mom.
她是一位妈妈。
Just while we're talking about all the insane elements of this episode, what are your memories, both of you of Britney Spears?
当我们谈论这一集的所有疯狂元素时，你们对布兰妮·斯皮尔斯的记忆是什么？
Cause this was, this was coming out of the strike.
因为这是罢工造成的。
So we're coming out of the writer's gold strike, right?
所以我们即将摆脱作家的淘金之旅，对吧？
We haven't aired for three months.
我们已经三个月没有播出了。
You scrubs or how much a mother.
你擦洗还是多少妈妈。
We were a younger show than you guys, Sarah.
我们是比你们更年轻的节目，莎拉。
You had been on a few years longer than us.
你比我们多了几年。
We were not a hit yet.
我们还没有很受欢迎。
And we were left wondering when that strike hit, like are we coming back after this strike?
我们想知道罢工何时发生，比如这次罢工后我们会回来吗？
We're not some massive hit.
我们不是什么大热门。
Hollywood's losing all this money.
好莱坞正在损失所有这些钱。
Are we on the chopping luck?
我们运气好吗？
So when we came back out of that strike, we were like, we are going big.
因此，当我们从罢工中恢复过来时，我们就想，我们要做大事了。
We are going to sing for our supper and the loudest voice we can.
我们将为我们的晚餐而唱歌，并尽可能大声地唱歌。
And it was like Sarah Jock, two minute date, Britney Spears.
就像莎拉·乔克（Sarah Jock）的两分钟约会，布兰妮·斯皮尔斯（Britney Spears）。
And you really just landed in our little world in a very weird moment, where we're like, manically shot out of this gate, trying to be like, we're gonna prove that we're worth keeping around for these nine episodes.
你真的只是在一个非常奇怪的时刻降落在我们的小世界里，我们就像，疯狂地从这扇门里射出来，试图表现得像，我们要证明我们值得在这九集里留下来。
And Britney comes in, they're literally as we're shooting it, helicopters flying over the Fox lot with paparazzi photographers trying to get photos of her, you know, walking from the car to our table reader, whatever it is, or to the set.
布兰妮进来了，就在我们拍摄的时候，直升机飞过福克斯的场地，狗仔队摄影师试图给她拍照，你知道，从车里走到我们的读台器那里，不管是什么，或者去片场。
There was such scrutiny on her.
她受到了如此多的审视。
She had been in the news, there had been a lot going on in her life.
她曾出现在新闻中，她的生活中发生了很多事情。
This was sort of her coming back out of having, I think a bit of a hard time, and coming back and working, and doing something everyone was so curious.
我觉得这有点像她从一段艰难的时期中回来，回来工作，做一些每个人都很好奇的事情。
What's your guys' memory of how that part felt?
你们对那部分的记忆如何？
She was, by the way, great in the episode.
顺便说一句，她在这一集中表现得很棒。
I was delighted by how beautiful and hilarious she was, and she was really good, and she was total, she was professional and great to work with.
我对她的美丽和搞笑感到很高兴，她真的很好，她很全面，她很专业，很适合合作。
But what was your memory of like, what, how strange that felt, the scrutiny left.
但你的记忆是什么，什么，感觉多么奇怪，审视留下了。
Sarah, I have a very strong memory of something you said that made me laugh so hard.
莎拉，我对你说的那些让我笑得很厉害的事情记忆犹新。
Like, I think people, like Sarah and I were, like kind of getting known for being on TV, but like being a series regular on a beloved show is a whole different world than what the kind of like fame and scrutiny a Britney Spears was under.
就像，我认为像莎拉和我这样的人，就像因上电视而出名一样，但就像成为一部受人喜爱的节目的常客一样，这与布兰妮·斯皮尔斯所受到的名声和审查是完全不同的世界。
Like it's like, I think we felt like a different species of a famous person had come to the set.
就像这样，我想我们感觉就像一个不同种类的名人来到了片场。
That was not like a working actor kind of vibe.
这不像是一个职业演员的氛围。
Like she was so iconically famous.
就像她如此出名一样。
She was so at that point had been like kind of torn apart.
那一刻她就像被撕裂了一样。
Like my heart went out to her.
就像我的心向她倾诉一样。
It was like really, and she was on this kind of like, trying to kind of repair things and come back.
就好像真的一样，她就是这样，试图修复一些东西然后回来。
And but I remember it was this feeling of like, what do we say to her?
但我记得那种感觉就像是，我们该对她说什么？
Like how do we communicate?
比如我们如何沟通？
but I remember you came up to a couple of us and you said, well, I had like three things to talk about.
但我记得你走到我们几个面前说，好吧，我有三件事要谈。
I talked about all of them and I'm out of stuff to talk about like you had like your things.
我谈论了所有这些，但我没有什么可谈论的，就像你喜欢你的事情一样。
You're like, you gave it a go.
你就像，你尝试了一下。
And then you kind of ran out of things and you kind of came back to us.
然后你就耗尽了所有的东西，然后又回到了我们身边。
And it just really made me laugh.
这真的让我笑了。
Do you remember that?
你还记得吗？
I remember wanting to like, you know, have her feel comfortable because I imagined that, You know, that level of, I remember being kind of blown away by that level of scrutiny she's under, like the helicopter circling, just trying to get a picture of her, the fact that everybody had to wear wristbands onto the- I forgot about that, to get onto the stage.
我记得我想让她感到舒服，因为我想象，你知道，那种程度，我记得被她所受到的那种程度的审视所震惊，就像直升机盘旋，只是想给她拍张照片，事实上每个人都必须戴上腕带——我忘了​​这一点，才能上舞台。
To get onto the stage, because only time that ever happened.
登上舞台，因为只有那一次发生过。
Only time that was like, I was like, oh, wow, this is pretty tight, tight, we run a tight ship here.
唯一的一次，我就想，哦，哇，这非常紧，紧，我们在这里运行得很紧。
We don't have wristbands at Scrum.
我们 Scrum 没有腕带。
But then I realized, oh, that's what we did this week.
但后来我意识到，哦，这就是我们本周所做的。
And like, it is not the norm, and that it's because obviously she runs into that.
就像，这不是常态，因为显然她遇到了这种情况。
And like, I can't imagine what it would be like to live under that level of scrutiny all of the time and to not just be a person that you meet, but to be like, you know, somebody who only needs to go by a first name and everybody knows who you're talking about.
就像，我无法想象一直生活在这种程度的审查之下会是什么样子，不仅是你遇到的一个人，而且是一个只需要叫出名字的人，每个人都知道你在谈论谁。
And yeah, I remember that.
是的，我记得。
I remember we talked about, I think, pets.
我记得我们谈论过宠物。
And then I remember my other memory of her was like, of her was like, you know, she was really, obviously doesn't have like a big background in comedy and she did so great.
然后我记得我对她的其他记忆就像，你知道，她真的，显然没有喜剧方面的大背景，但她做得很好。
Like that scene when she's, when you know, she's like, I'll let her know when you're asking to see Stella and she's like, and you're like, what, telepathically?
就像那个场景，当她，当你知道的时候，她就像，当你要求见斯特拉时我会让她知道，她就像，你就像，什么，心灵感应？
Because she doesn't move.
因为她不动。
And then her laugh after and she's like, that's funny, dad.
然后她笑了，她说，这很有趣，爸爸。
That's funny, smart and great.
这很有趣、聪明而且很棒。
Funny, smart and great.
有趣、聪明、伟大。
That was my favorite line of hers.
这是我最喜欢她的台词。
Me too.
我也是。
And so genuine.
而且如此真诚。
And like, I remember thinking like, wow, that's like, cool that she can come in and do that.
我记得我当时想，哇，这真是太酷了，她能进来做到这一点。
Do you know what I remember, correct?
你知道我记得什么吗？
You know what I thought when I was watching the show, Craig, was I thought you guys did her a really big service, which was you didn't spotlight her as the center of the show.
你知道我在看节目时的想法，克雷格，我认为你们为她做了很大的贡献，那就是你们没有将她作为节目的中心。
She was like a side comedic character in the show.
她就像剧中的一个喜剧角色。
Incredibly well used, incredibly funny, but she's not part of the main romance of the show.
非常好用，非常有趣，但她并不是这部剧的主要爱情故事的一部分。
That was Sarah and I.
那是莎拉和我。
Yeah.
是的。
And she also was like, she wasn't the object of desire.
她也觉得，她不是欲望的对象。
she was the one who was yearning.
她就是那个向往的人。
Yeah, and I think that was so smart to take her because she'd been so objectified her whole life.
是的，我认为带走她是非常明智的，因为她一生都被物化了。
Yeah, since she was a teenager to turn her into this incredibly sweet, earnest character that was, you just didn't slather her with her persona.
是的，从她十几岁的时候起，就把她变成这个令人难以置信的甜蜜、认真的角色，你只是没有用她的人格来丰富她。
Yeah, and I think it allowed her to give like this really sharp, really funny character turn.
是的，我认为这让她能够做出如此尖锐、非常有趣的性格转变。
Yeah, I agree.
是的，我同意。
That's a good point.
这是一个很好的观点。
She leaned into it.
她倾身进去。
So her, she was like, she knew that assignment.
所以她，她就像，她知道那个任务。
She was like, I'm longing for this guy who's looking right past me.
她说，我渴望这个在我身边看着的人。
And I'm gonna act that part and be in Aussie.
我将扮演这个角色并在澳大利亚演出。
And she almost seemed relieved not to be the center of it.
她似乎因为没有成为这件事的中心而松了口气。
I think that's right.
我认为这是对的。
I think it was the best for everybody.
我认为这对每个人来说都是最好的。
You know, I also have a strong memory in it.
你知道，我也有很强的记忆力在里面。
And I've always been grateful for her, for this.
为此，我一直很感激她。
TV Guide wanted to photograph her and put her on the cover.
电视指南想给她拍照并让她登上封面。
And she said, I'll only do it if Josh is next to me.
她说，只有乔什在我旁边我才会这样做。
like she didn't want to be alone.
就像她不想一个人呆着一样。
She wanted to be with like someone from the show.
她想像剧中的某个人一样在一起。
So Britney Spears and I ended up on the cover of TV guide together.
所以布兰妮·斯皮尔斯和我最终一起登上了电视指南的封面。
Oh my God, we've had weird lives.
天哪，我们的生活很奇怪。
Yeah, we've had strange lives.
是的，我们的生活很奇怪。
And I remember, I made a joke that I don't think she was kind of thrown by it, but they were taking our picture.
我记得，我开了个玩笑，我不认为她对此感到惊讶，但他们正在给我们拍照。
And I just leaned over, I was like, is this your photo?
我就靠过来，我想，这是你的照片吗？
I said, is this your first photo shoot?
我说，这是你第一次拍写真吗？
And she looked at me like, what?
她看着我，好像在问什么？
You nervous?
你紧张吗？
I was like, you know, but I always, I always thought it was a very, I know it was like, for her, she didn't want to be spot lit in that way.
我当时想，你知道，但我一直，我一直认为这是非常，我知道这就像，对她来说，她不想以这种方式成为聚光灯下的焦点。
She was like, I'm doing this show.
她说，我正在做这个节目。
I'd rather like be a part of the show.
我宁愿成为演出的一部分。
Yeah.
是的。
Yes.
But she really, I was told they were like, she didn't want to do the shoot without you.
但有人告诉我，她真的不想在没有你的情况下进行拍摄。
She asked if you would, would be with her.
她问你是否愿意，愿意和她在一起吗？
That's really nice.
那真是太好了。
And it's her, yeah, it's her wanting to say, I know I'm part, I'm joining the show for this thing.
是的，是她想说，我知道我是其中的一部分，我参加这个节目就是为了这件事。
It's not the me show and that was her, that was her energy.
这不是我的表演，那是她，那是她的能量。
She knew how to fit into the episode and do what was needed.
她知道如何融入情节并做需要做的事情。
There was something, I was really startled at her innocence, her ability to play, not play, I'm not playing three different meanings to this, I'm playing the surface level which is where that character lived, but it was so sincere and so sweet and it was even funnier than I remembered it and I remembered it being funny.
有一些东西，我真的对她的纯真感到震惊，她玩的能力，不玩的能力，我不是在玩这三种不同的含义，我正在玩表面层，也就是那个角色居住的地方，但它是如此真诚，如此甜蜜，甚至比我记忆中的更有趣，我记得它很有趣。
I totally agree.
我完全同意。
And when she went and did that piece with Neil, where Abby and Barney come in the turquoise like v-neck sweaters, and she's pretending they're doing the bit together, or he's doing the bit to bug.
当她和尼尔一起表演那段戏时，艾比和巴尼穿着像 V 领毛衣一样的绿松石色，她假装他们正在一起做这件事，或者他正在做那件事来打扰。
Yes.
是的。
And I'm glad that's your character.
我很高兴这就是你的性格。
Like a couple episodes later.
就像几集之后。
Yeah.
是的。
And she was fantastic.
她太棒了。
And in that same way, you know, like just kind of buying the fact that he's proposing to her.
同样，你知道，就像是相信他向她求婚的事实。
She's good.
她很好。
She's a good guy.
她是个好人。
She's like she really...
她就像她真的...
It must have gone well for her that she came back.
她回来对她来说一定很顺利。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
I remember Pam being incredibly kind to her, like just achingly kind because I think there was a sense of like, this poor girl, it was like, almost what we were, I gave Craig this award the other night, Sarah, at this event and Monica Lewinsky, who's a friend of mine, but she was honored and she talked a lot about how when other people tell your story and it takes your story away from you and you're not allowed to tell your own story.
我记得帕姆对她非常友善，就像是非常友善，因为我认为有一种感觉，这个可怜的女孩，就像我们一样，那天晚上我在这次活动中给了克雷格这个奖项，莎拉，还有我的朋友莫妮卡·莱温斯基，但她很荣幸，她谈到了很多关于当其他人讲述你的故事时，它会夺走你的故事，而你不被允许讲述自己的故事。
And as, you know, her podcast called Reclaiming, and I felt like that was kind of Britney Spears like first step on the road back to reclaiming her own story, because it had been absolutely hijacked from her and this old man, he musted me, fell in love with you, New York City.
你知道，她的播客名为“回收”，我觉得这有点像布兰妮·斯皮尔斯回归自己故事的第一步，因为它完全被她劫持了，而这个老人，他必须我，爱上了你，纽约市。
And now commercials, end of commercials back to show, you, you, you, you, you, you started having a lot of scrutiny on you at a young age Sarah, right?
现在广告，广告结束回到节目，你，你，你，你，你，你在年轻的时候就开始受到很多审视，莎拉，对吧？
You were like, you've begun this job pretty, this career pretty early.
你说，你很早就开始了这份工作，这份职业生涯。
You must have had some connection to that.
你一定与此有某种联系。
It seems when you're talking about your memories of Britain, you seem like you have a great deal of empathy for where she was at this moment.
当你谈论你对英国的记忆时，你似乎对她此时此刻的处境非常同情。
Yeah, I mean, I would never even begin to compare, like I had, you know, I had started doing musical theater as a kid.
是的，我的意思是，我什至不会开始比较，就像我小时候开始做音乐剧一样。
I was actually like professionally working until grade 12, which is Canadian for 12th grade.
事实上，直到 12 年级，我都喜欢专业工作，这是加拿大的 12 年级。
And I feel like at that point, yeah, it was sort of like jumping into all of it at once, because it was like the number one show, Roseanne was number one show on TV at the time, and I had really barely worked and kind of had no business being there.
我觉得在那一点上，是的，这有点像立即跳入所有这一切，因为它就像第一名节目，《罗珊娜》是当时电视上的第一名节目，而我真的几乎没有工作，也没有必要在那里。
And I do remember that feeling of all of it happening at once, both getting recognized and being at an age where you kind of just want to blend, you're like about to go into first university and that was when it was carrying through and to that time and just kind of like all of it.
我确实记得所有这一切同时发生的感觉，既得到认可，又处于一个你只想融入的年龄，你就像即将进入第一所大学，那是它正在进行的时候，就像所有这一切一样。
Like I remember going to the first red carpet and I had a pair of shoes and my mom was like do you want to buy shoes that actually match the dress you're wearing and I'm like why would I do that?
就像我记得第一次走红地毯时，我有一双鞋子，我妈妈问你想买与你穿的衣服真正相配的鞋子吗？我问我为什么要这么做？
I have a perfectly good pair of shoes and I went up on the worst dress list and I didn't really care about that but it was like so real.
我有一双非常好的鞋子，而且我上了最差着装名单，我并不太在意这一点，但它就像是那么真实。
It was like that kind of thing, right?
就是这样的事情，对吧？
Like you're sort of going like okay I'm you know show up on Sunday it's Battle of the Network and I'm like, okay, and I get there, and I'm like, where's the rest of my cast?
就像你有点像，好吧，你知道周日会出现网络之战，我想，好吧，我到了那里，我想，我的其他演员在哪里？
I just thought it was like something you did, but it was superstar American gladiators, and they hand you like sports bra and hot pants, and there's like a volcano with a gladiator at the top, and you're clambering up a wet volcano in spandex.
我只是觉得这就像你所做的事情，但那是美国超级明星角斗士，他们给你的就像运动胸罩和热裤，就像一座火山，顶部有一个角斗士，而你正在用氨纶爬上一座潮湿的火山。
Wait, you said you never played sports?
等等，你说你从来没有参加过体育运动？
That sounds like sports.
这听起来像体育运动。
That and the two men's day.
那天和两个男人的日子。
That's the nerves, that's the nerves.
这就是神经，这就是神经。
Those are my two, that's that and limbo, and race walking, that's all I got.
这是我的两个，就是这样，还有地狱，还有竞走，这就是我所拥有的一切。
But I feel like, yeah, there were so many things like that where it was just like baptism by fire and you kind of jumping into it.
但我觉得，是的，有很多类似的事情，就像经历了火的洗礼，你就跳进去了。
And I guess, you know, I can't imagine though, like that was such a microcosm, like a 0.001% of what her life must have felt like.
我想，你知道，我无法想象，就像那是一个缩影，就像她生活的 0.001% 一样。
Yeah, I mean, she, she seemed, she carried that with her.
是的，我的意思是，她，她似乎，她随身带着这个。
I remember like when the cameras were off, she seemed like she wanted, I understand what you say when you're like, I used up my three things because the energy was like, how do I talk to her?
我记得当摄像机关闭时，她似乎想要，我理解你说的话，当你喜欢时，我用完了我的三件事，因为能量就像，我如何与她交谈？
How do I connect with her?
我如何与她联系？
Or does she not want that?
还是她不想这样？
And I think that's, her whole life is everyone around her was feeling that way.
我认为她的一生都是她周围的每个人都有这种感觉。
And how do you connect with her?
你如何与她联系？
And it must be a very lonely feeling to know that everyone is trying to figure out how to talk to you and if they should.
知道每个人都在试图弄清楚如何与你交谈以及是否应该与你交谈，这一定是一种非常孤独的感觉。
And that's a spooky climate to live in.
那是一种令人毛骨悚然的居住气候。
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah, it's, fame is, Jordana and I have talked about this.
是的，名声就是，乔丹娜和我讨论过这个。
like she thinks that sudden fame or even infamy, like when the culture just spotlights you and kind of lifts you up and tears you down, like she thinks that should be in the DSM as a like mental disorder of what it can do to you of how destabilizing it can be.
就像她认为突然成名甚至臭名昭著，就像当文化只是关注你并让你振奋并让你失望时，就像她认为这应该在 DSM 中作为一种类似的精神障碍，它可以对你造成多大的破坏。
And there, I don't think there's been enough kind of research in certain ways into how just the roller coaster of all of that.
在那里，我认为在某些方面还没有足够的研究来探讨这一切如何像过山车一样。
And also like, yeah, I was genuinely confused how to talk to her and approach her.
而且，是的，我真的很困惑如何与她交谈并接近她。
And like exactly what you said, like, does she want to talk to us?
正如你所说，她想和我们谈谈吗？
Like, I'm sure she was like aching to be a normal person who could just shoot the shit, you know?
就像，我确信她渴望成为一个可以开枪的普通人，你知道吗？
But I felt like we dealt with it as well as we could.
但我觉得我们已经尽力处理好了。
as well as we could.
尽我们所能。
I mean, we were trying to create a very safe space for her as we were trying to do for all the guest stars.
我的意思是，我们试图为她创造一个非常安全的空间，就像我们试图为所有客串明星做的那样。
But this was like our first real, like, we had a lot of like wild kind of celebrity appearances on the show.
但这就像我们第一次真正的那样，我们在节目中出现了很多类似狂野的名人。
You guys had amazing guest stars on that show.
你们在那个节目中客串了很棒的明星。
A cool run.
很酷的跑步。
But this one I think was, it was on another level of something culturally.
但我认为这是在文化的另一个层面上。
This was different.
这是不同的。
Yeah, this was different.
是的，这是不同的。
My memory of my weird experience with her was We were having some sort of a relaunch party.
我对与她的奇怪经历的记忆是我们正在举办某种重新启动派对。
There was a publicity party for High Match Mother that week, Sarah.
莎拉，那周有一场“高配妈妈”的宣传派对。
I mean, you probably couldn't come because you probably were shooting scrubs later that night or going to, you don't remember, I have no memory of the party, really, but it was like a publicity, like we're back on the air.
我的意思是，你可能不能来，因为那天晚上你可能正在拍摄磨砂膏，或者要去，你不记得了，我真的不记得聚会，但这就像一次宣传，就像我们重新开始直播一样。
It was an event, it was all schmoozy and very Hollywood.
这是一场盛事，一切都很闲聊，而且非常好莱坞。
And I was, somehow I got voted to invite Britney Spears to it and I was given a card, like a little card, invitation card and like center her trailer that was for her and like I knocked on her door and she opened the door and I kind of got this like these sweats where she's like I'm about to ask how Britney Spears on a date basically like I've got this little invitation like hey Britney this is probably stupid we've got this thing on Thursday night me I don't know if it's probably dumb but maybe when I come and like awkwardly asked her out to this thing essentially and like and she was like very pledge is like thank you and I remember like walking away and being like why did I agree to do this who like I don't know how I got voted to be the person to do this but I basically like failed at asking out Britney Spears because she did not come to the event but it is it was one of those events that you I felt this you know when the when the Victoria's secret models were on it's just one of those events where Sarah you know everyone's in a while you because I think when you when you're on a TV show you metabolize it pretty quickly You're like, this is my job.
我，不知何故，我被投票邀请布兰妮·斯皮尔斯参加，我收到了一张卡片，就像一张小卡片，邀请卡，就像中间她的预告片一样，是给她的，就像我敲了她的门，她打开了门，我有点像这些汗水，她就像我要问布兰妮·斯皮尔斯如何约会，基本上就像我收到了这张小邀请一样，嘿布兰妮，这可能很愚蠢，我们在周四晚上收到了这件事我我不知道这可能是愚蠢的，但也许当我来的时候，就像尴尬地邀请她参加这件事，她就像非常承诺，就像谢谢你一样，我记得就像走开一样，就像我为什么同意这样做一样，我不知道我是如何被选为这样做的人，但我基本上喜欢失败地邀请布兰妮·斯皮尔斯，因为她没有来参加活动，但这正是你我感觉到的那些活动之一，你知道当维多利亚的时候秘密模特在这只是莎拉你知道每个人都在一段时间内的活动之一，因为我认为当你在电视节目中时你会很快代谢它你就像，这是我的工作。
These are my coworkers, no big deal.
这些都是我的同事，没什么大不了的。
But then there's every once in a while, something comes along that you're like, life is weird out here.
但每隔一段时间，就会发生一些事情，让你觉得这里的生活很奇怪。
Like this is a strange, I'm the only person from my high school class that is currently like having this weirdness in their life, you know?
这很奇怪，我是高中班上唯一一个在生活中遇到这种奇怪的人，你知道吗？
A hundred percent.
百分之一百。
I remember we did an episode of Scrubs and I'm sure this was like for you guys too.
我记得我们拍过一集《实习医生风云》，我相信你们也一样。
When you find out someone's coming, you're like, oh my God, who's gonna get to have scenes with this person?
当你发现有人要来时，你会想，天啊，谁能和这个人拍戏呢？
This is like so exciting.
这真是太令人兴奋了。
I hope I get to have scenes with them.
我希望我能和他们一起拍戏。
And then the sides come through the fax machine because it was back in the days of fact machines.
然后双方通过传真机传送，因为那是在事实机器时代。
And sometimes we get, you know, scenes the night before.
有时我们会看到前一天晚上的场景。
Michael J.
迈克尔·J。
Fox was coming on and he was my idol, like all growing up.
福克斯即将登场，他是我的偶像，就像所有成长过程中的偶像一样。
And I was like, oh my God, I hope I get to have scenes with him.
我当时想，天哪，我希望我能和他一起上演。
And yeah, I'd come through the fact machine and my storyline was with him.
是的，我是通过事实机器得知的，我的故事情节是和他在一起的。
I was so excited.
我很兴奋。
And good storyline was an epiphany toilet.
好的故事情节是顿悟厕所。
And so my first scene was like my idol.
所以我的第一个场景就像我的偶像。
I had to have my pants around my ankle, sitting on a toilet.
我不得不把裤子套在脚踝上，坐在马桶上。
I'm just like, really?
我只是想，真的吗？
We've had weird lives.
我们都过着奇怪的生活。
Lord giveth and the Lord takeeth away.
赐予的是主，收取的也是主。
Very, very wise.
非常非常明智。
This was the weirdest possible episode for you to jump into.
这是你可能跳入的最奇怪的一集。
And I forgot exactly how last minute it was.
我完全忘记了那是最后一刻。
Yeah, I forgot that too.
是的，我也忘记了。
I forgot.
我忘了。
Yes, mid episode.
是的，中间一集。
What do you do to mentally prepare to come jump into this show?
为了参加这个节目，你做了哪些心理准备？
How did you feel trying to do this while also doing scrubs?
在做磨砂的同时尝试这样做感觉如何？
I feel like I want to know more about how weird that was.
我觉得我想更多地了解这有多奇怪。
You know, I actually, to be honest, memory of it is not weird at all it was more just like it was just fun and almost in the same way that the two-minute date felt like a dance it felt like a bit of a dance you know like like kind of like okay doing this and and I think that's a really a tribute to you guys because it very quickly like we're talking very quickly like my memory that was right away felt extremely comfortable and obviously like as an actor like everyone's gonna do their best work when they're comfortable and I you know I think I'd met Kobe before, because all Canadians have met.
你知道，说实话，我对它的记忆一点也不奇怪，它更像是很有趣，几乎就像两分钟的约会感觉就像一场舞蹈，感觉有点像一场你知道喜欢的舞蹈，就像好吧这样做，我认为这真的是对你们的致敬，因为它很快就像我们说话很快，就像我的记忆一样，立刻感觉非常舒服，显然就像作为一个演员，每个人都会在舒服的时候尽自己最大的努力我想我以前见过科比，因为所有加拿大人都见过。
And then Cooper, too.
然后库珀也是。
And Cooper's a small enough town.
库珀是一个足够小的城镇。
I think you guys did know each other a little, right?
我想你们确实有点了解，对吧？
Yeah.
是的。
Just like, but just the teens.
就像，但只是青少年。
We got to know each other much more on the show.
我们在节目中更加了解彼此。
But, you know, Craig, you and Carter were so welcoming.
但是，你知道，克雷格，你和卡特非常热情。
Josh, you were so welcoming.
乔希，你真是太热情了。
The whole cast was so welcoming.
整个演员阵容都很受欢迎。
So it was just like, it was just right away fun.
所以就好像，马上就很有趣。
I was like, oh, this is fun.
我当时想，哦，这很有趣。
And like we were saying, like it's a different vibe to be doing, you know, like the run through and like the mini play.
就像我们说的，就像这是一种不同的氛围，你知道，就像贯穿和迷你剧一样。
And that was, I think on the, I think it was a run through the first day I got there.
我认为这就是我到达那里的第一天的经历。
And then the second thing, it was one on the Tuesday and one on the Wednesday.
然后是第二件事，一件是周二，一件是周三。
And it was not- You just walked into our run through immediately.
事实并非如此——你只是立即走进了我们的运行过程。
It was so fun.
太有趣了。
And you didn't attend the table read.
而且你没有参加桌读。
You just came in.
你刚进来。
No, I did not attend the table read.
不，我没有参加表读。
I was not at the table read.
我不在桌旁读书。
Having guests start on shows before, I actually found, I find it to be one of the hardest things because you're really going into someone else's living room and trying to get the lay out of the land.
事实上，我发现，之前让嘉宾开始表演是最困难的事情之一，因为你真的要走进别人的客厅，并试图摆脱困境。
So I think we all just tried to make it really easy for guest stars to come on board.
所以我认为我们都只是尽力让客串明星更容易加入。
But my memory of you is that you were just like, it felt like you were the sixth beat all of a sudden.
但我对你的记忆是，你就像，感觉你突然变成了第六拍。
Like you were very calm.
就像你很平静一样。
Like you just were like, you knew how to be on a set.
就像你一样，你知道如何在片场。
You knew the, you just understood.
你知道，你刚刚明白了。
You fit in so immediately.
你很快就适应了。
You fit in so well.
你很适合。
Yeah.
是的。
We all, everybody there loved you.
我们所有人，那里的每个人都爱你。
We were so lucky to have you.
我们很幸运有你。
I didn't feel guilty making you be a doctor again.
让你再次成为一名医生我并不感到内疚。
That was ridiculous.
那太荒谬了。
And I want to re-apologize for both that.
我想为此再次道歉。
and the leaving at the altar thing.
还有离开祭坛的事。
Other than that, it was a gracious experience.
除此之外，这是一次愉快的经历。
Well, no, I mean, I feel like it was a Tuesday.
嗯，不，我是说，我觉得那是星期二。
The character was already written.
人物已经写好了。
It was no change.
没有任何变化。
I know, I can't overemphasize how last minute and out of control and insane.
我知道，我怎么强调都不为过，最后一刻是多么失控和疯狂。
There was nine episodes in 10 and a half weeks, and most of them were not written.
10周半的时间有9集，大部分都没有写完。
We had we went on strike and they shot one.
我们罢工了，他们开枪打死了一个。
We had one other script we had like fully prepared.
我们还有另外一个剧本，我们已经做好了充分的准备。
They shot one without us.
他们在没有我们的情况下开枪了。
And coming out of the strike, we had so little.
罢工结束后，我们所拥有的东西非常少。
We weren't secretly hiding in our homes and writing lots of scripts.
我们并没有偷偷躲在家里写很多剧本。
We were good boys, we were good writers, guild members, but as a result, we came out and it was just like, holy fuck, what are we gonna do?
我们是好男孩，我们是好作家，公会成员，但结果，我们出来了，就像，天啊，我们要做什么？
And the fact that it all came together, this is a great How I Met Your Mother episode.
事实上，这一切都汇集在一起​​，这是一部很棒的《老爸老妈的浪漫史》剧集。
I love this episode.
我喜欢这一集。
The two minute, you're so charming and you're such a fantastic romantic comedy actor.
那两分钟，你是如此迷人，你是一位出色的浪漫喜剧演员。
You're such a fantastic actor in general, but like the two minute date, Brittany, like the things that this episode had to do against her in 22 minutes, less 21 to 50 or something, it achieves a lot in that time.
总的来说，你是一位非常棒的演员，但就像布列塔尼的两分钟约会，就像这一集在 22 分钟内对她做的事情，少了 21 到 50 之类的，在那段时间里取得了很多成就。
I think it really holds up.
我认为它确实站得住脚。
I think it's really great.
我认为这真的很棒。
And I don't know how we did it.
我不知道我们是怎么做到的。
I don't know how we were really lucky to get you to do it.
我不知道我们是如何幸运地让你做到这一点的。
You know what's striking me about this episode is like, we talk about sometimes how I met your mother, Sarah, are like really plot.
你知道这一集让我印象深刻的是，我们有时会谈论我如何遇见你的母亲莎拉，就像真正的情节一样。
The plot is very impressive, the way we tell the story, the kind of jumps.
情节非常令人印象深刻，我们讲故事的方式，那种跳跃。
And then other ones are just like really funny, like joke machines.
然后其他的就真的很有趣，就像笑话机器一样。
I feel like this one does both of those things.
我觉得这个人可以做这两件事。
It really moves the chess piece forward of the main story.
它确实将棋子向前推进了主要故事。
I love the fake out.
我喜欢假货。
I had forgotten about this when Stella says, oh, I went to a St.
当斯特拉说，哦，我去了圣路易斯教堂时，我已经忘记了这一点。
Patrick's Day party, but I left early.
圣帕特里克节聚会，但我提前离开了。
Yes.
是的。
And that's like kind of like, cause we know the mother was there.
这有点像，因为我们知道母亲在那里。
The number of bells and whistles in this episode, cause that was a little hint.
这一集中有很多花里胡哨的东西，因为这是一个小暗示。
Like maybe you could be the mother.
就像也许你可以成为母亲。
Maybe she would be the mother.
也许她会成为母亲。
And we had said the mother was at the St.
我们说过母亲在圣路易斯医院。
Patrick's Day party before one of the episodes before the strike hit.
罢工前一集之前的圣帕特里克节派对。
And so that was it.
就是这样。
We really were doing everything in this episode.
我们真的在这一集中做了所有的事情。
But I feel like when people talk about this episode, they would talk about two things, the two minute date, which kind of became iconic for the show.
但我觉得当人们谈论这一集时，他们会谈论两件事，两分钟的约会，这成为了该剧的标志。
And then Britney Spears being on the episode.
然后布兰妮·斯皮尔斯也出现在这一集中。
But if you watch the episode, joke for joke, it's fantastic.
但如果你看这一集，一个又一个笑话，那就太棒了。
Like, I think every joke lands, they're really like character specific jokes.
就像，我认为每个笑话都很受欢迎，它们真的很像特定于角色的笑话。
It comes at you so fast.
它来得如此之快。
There's so many scenes.
有很多场景。
It's got this great propulsion to it.
它有如此强大的推动力。
I was pretty delighted at just how well it worked as like a great How I May or Mother episode on its merits.
我对它的效果感到非常高兴，就像一部出色的《How I May》或《Mother》剧集的优点一样。
Oh my God, I agree.
天哪，我同意。
I mean, the writing is always fantastic.
我的意思是，写作总是很棒。
And I love the, you know, I think, like if you just look at just this episode, the number of different, like the joke for joke, but also the moving stuff, but also like it draws you in.
我喜欢，你知道，我想，就像你只看这一集一样，有很多不同的东西，比如一个又一个的笑话，还有令人感动的东西，而且也喜欢它吸引你。
There's like runners that are so fun to do.
就像跑步一样，做起来很有趣。
I think that's why the show is so fun to do as an actor because you get to do all these different things.
我认为这就是为什么作为一名演员，这部剧如此有趣，因为你可以做所有这些不同的事情。
Like there's the two minute date, but there's also, you know, real, real moments where like, Stella's explained to Ted, like I would love to do this, but I actually can't.
就像有两分钟的约会，但也有，你知道，真实的时刻，就像斯特拉向泰德解释的那样，就像我很乐意这样做，但实际上我不能。
And this is why.
这就是原因。
And then, like the fun kind of like really pacey stuff, like I loved, I'd forgotten about it until re-watching it, you know, that little bit with Stella and Ted in the office where I can't remember because I was like, you know, who's Abby is my receptionist, who's Allen?
然后，就像那种有趣的、真正节奏很快的东西，就像我喜欢的那样，我都忘了它，直到重新观看它，你知道，斯特拉和泰德在办公室里的那一点我不记得了，因为我想，你知道，谁是艾比是我的接待员，谁是艾伦？
I thought you said Allen.
我以为你说的是​​艾伦。
That's a straight, like, classic Hollywood.
这就是典型的好莱坞电影。
You guys were doing Avon and Costello.
你们正在做雅芳和科斯特洛。
That's Avon, Costello.
那是雅芳，科斯特洛。
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊，是啊，是啊。
Do you know what else is like that a little bit, which I had totally forgotten, is the game of telephone in the movie theater, where Ted thinks he's on a date, and like everyone having to go back for Ted thinks he's on a date.
你知道还有什么类似的事吗，我完全忘记了，是电影院里的电话游戏，泰德认为他在约会，就像每个人都必须回去一样，泰德认为他在约会。
Ted thinks he's on a date.
特德认为他正在约会。
We all got it.
我们都明白了。
Ted's a schmuck.
特德是个笨蛋。
It goes against anime rules.
这违反了动漫规则。
I got it.
我得到了它。
That was so funny.
那太有趣了。
And it's like, Ted's a schmuck.
就好像，特德是个傻瓜。
Like when I heard him say that line, I felt like I was there yesterday.
就像当我听到他说那句话时，我感觉就像昨天我在那里一样。
Like that to me feels recent, whereas the whole experience feels like a long time ago.
对我来说，这感觉就像是最近发生的事情，而整个经历却感觉像是很久以前的事了。
Oh, that's so funny.
哦，那太有趣了。
That was the part that stayed with you.
那是留在你身边的部分。
I was like, oh my God.
我当时想，天啊。
I was like, oh, we were just there.
我当时想，哦，我们就在那里。
We were just here.
我们刚刚在这里。
Yeah.
是的。
I love Ted's caterpillar joke at the beginning.
我喜欢泰德开头的毛毛虫笑话。
Like, I like it when Ted has like good lines.
就像，我喜欢特德有同样好的台词。
Like that's a very good line.
就像这是一条非常好的路线。
Like I got a caterpillar.
就像我得到了一条毛毛虫。
I didn't realize what he said.
我没有意识到他说了什么。
I didn't realize he would bloom this.
没想到他会开出这样的花。
Yeah, that was pretty good.
是的，那很好。
That was great.
那很棒。
And it's him making something charming out of the fact that he has a fucking butterfly tattoo on his lower back, like that's a tough one.
他的下背部有一个该死的蝴蝶纹身，这让他变得很迷人，就像这是一个很难的纹身。
It's tough to make lemonade out of that, but Ted did it with President.
用它来制作柠檬水很困难，但特德和总统一起做到了。
The lower butterfly tattoo and Ted in the wood.
下部蝴蝶纹身和特德在树林里。
Ted, that was the best.
特德，那是最好的。
That is, that made me laugh at that moment.
也就是说，那一刻让我笑了。
Such a simple joke and such a good like visual joke.
如此简单的笑话，又如此美好的视觉笑话。
It's a little like take your daughter to work day reveal, you know?
这有点像带你女儿去上班，你知道吗？
Totally.
完全。
And juxtaposed from like the fact that they were just asking you in the conversation, how did that, how did the first meeting go?
与他们只是在谈话中问你的事实并列，第一次会议进行得怎么样？
And then how the first moment go.
然后第一时刻是如何进行的。
Yeah, I loved, uh, I have a very strong memory of that scream, Sarah.
是的，我喜欢，呃，我对那场尖叫有着非常强烈的记忆，莎拉。
Like when you, when I think I can take it, that was a funny screen.
就像当你，当我认为我可以接受它时，那是一个有趣的屏幕。
It's so good.
太好了。
That was such a good screen.
那是一个非常好的屏幕。
That's like, I went to drama school.
就像，我去了戏剧学校。
I had a supported breath for that.
我为此屏住了呼吸。
And then, and then when, um, Abby runs in, Dr.
然后，然后当，嗯，艾比跑进来时，博士。
Are you all right?
你还好吗？
I heard a woman screaming.
我听到一个女人的尖叫声。
Oh, Sarah.
哦，莎拉。
Your fall off the chair, your like, frat fall off the chair is so good.
你从椅子上摔下来，你的兄弟从椅子上摔下来真是太棒了。
It is, here's the highest compliment I can give you a physical comedy.
这是我能给你的肢体喜剧最高的赞美。
I thought it was Alice and Janney good.
我认为爱丽丝和珍妮很好。
You know how Alice and Janney's like the greatest faller?
你知道爱丽丝和珍妮是最伟大的摔跤手吗？
Like she falls off treadmills and she falls.
就像她从跑步机上摔下来然后摔倒一样。
I thought it was up there.
我以为它就在那里。
Like it was so funny.
好像这件事太有趣了。
And normally it looks like you can see them getting ready to fall.
通常情况下，你可以看到它们准备坠落。
Like I didn't see it, it was fantastic.
就像我没看到一样，太棒了。
Well, frat falls are maybe like top two of my favorite things to ever get to do.
嗯，兄弟会瀑布可能是我最喜欢做的两件事。
I love them.
我爱他们。
I've always loved them when we were doing scrubs.
当我们做磨砂膏时我一直很喜欢它们。
1.0, we would always ask to do them 2.0, I'm always like, oh my God, guys.
1.0，我们总是要求做 2.0，我总是想，天哪，伙计们。
But 1.0, we would always ask.
但是1.0，我们总是会问。
And I remember learning from the stunt guys, they were amazing to be able to explain to us about you cannot anticipate, like you can't or you're done.
我记得向特技演员学习，他们能够向我们解释“你无法预料”，就像你不能或你已经完成了一样，这真是太棒了。
And so in the pandemic, when it was just going on for so long and we were all taking turns, teaching our kids different skills, we were bubbling with a few other families somebody would come in and give a speech about like, you know, the rights of the child and someone else said I did prattful lessons for the kids and so I would like put a stack of Books and I would be like so when you're walking you may not the trick is is you walking and you're looking forward You can see it on your peripheral But the second before you hit it you turn away So it looks like you'd have absolutely no knowledge that it was coming and That was my contribution to my children and their friends pandemic lessons was a prattful class right before you hit it, you look over your shoulder to really seldomously, you do not, oh my God, that's good.
所以在大流行病中，当它持续了很长一段时间，我们都轮流教我们的孩子不同的技能时，我们和其他几个家庭一起泡泡，有人会进来发表关于儿童权利的演讲，还有人说我给孩子们上了一些废话，所以我想放一摞书，我会说，所以当你走路的时候，诀窍可能不是你走路，你在期待，你可以在你的外围设备上看到它，但是在你击中它之前的第二秒你转身离开所以看起来你完全不知道它即将到来，这是我对我的孩子和他们的朋友的贡献流行病课程在你击中它之前是一堂无聊的课，你很少回头看，你不知道，天哪，那很好。
This is over loosely.
至此就轻松结束了。
Something where you don't know that it's coming.
有些事情你不知道它即将到来。
I love it that you're like a student of the problem.
我喜欢你就像这个问题的学生。
You're a student.
你是一名学生。
You are an excellent physical comedian.
你是一位出色的肢体喜剧演员。
You really are good at it.
你真的很擅长。
It makes perfect sense that you've broken it down this much because you're really on scrubs.
你把它分解了这么多，这是完全有道理的，因为你真的在穿磨砂膏。
I feel like you did a lot of platforms on scrubs.
我觉得你在磨砂膏上做了很多平台。
I feel like you did a lot of physical comedy on the show and you're great at it.
我觉得你在剧中做了很多肢体喜剧，而且你很擅长。
I love that you were scientific in your process.
我喜欢你的过程很科学。
It got, it got very scientific.
它得到了，它变得非常科学。
I have broken it down, but I've also unfortunately broken things.
我已经把它弄坏了，但不幸的是我也弄坏了一些东西。
Like I, you know, am quite, you'd think at this point, I would have figured out where my body isn't spaced, but it hasn't quite happened.
就像我，你知道，我很安静，你可能会想，在这一点上，我会弄清楚我的身体在哪里没有间隔，但它还没有完全发生。
So I actually broke my finger the day before we went back to scrubs this year.
所以今年我们回去穿手术衣的前一天，我实际上把手指弄断了。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
But not, you've not, you've not gone injured when needing to fall for a job, you get injured outside of work.
但不是，你没有，你不是在需要找工作时受伤的，你是在工作之外受伤的。
Is that what you're saying?
你是这么说的吗？
Like right the day before like I'd always have to call Randall every season of scrubs and be like I'm gonna have to like just stand and not walk behind the the hospital bed because I stepped on a pine cone and Six weeks of season 9 remember crack.
就像前一天一样，每一季的磨砂膏我总是要给兰德尔打电话，就像我必须喜欢只是站着，而不是走在医院的病床后面，因为我踩到了一个松果，第九季的六周记得裂缝。
I was in a boot cuz I broke my fifth metatarsal on my you're in a boot I know Life happens outside of these shows and you have to figure it out on the show No.
我穿着靴子，因为我的第五跖骨骨折了，你穿着靴子，我知道生活发生在这些节目之外，你必须在节目中弄清楚。
My son is currently in a boot for breaking his fifth metatarsal.
我儿子目前因第五跖骨骨折而正在接受治疗。
Oh, wow.
哦，哇。
Oh, my God.
我的天啊。
Fifth metatarsal buddy.
第五跖骨伙伴。
Your Canadian for a second, I thought you meant the trunk of a car, so I'm actually relieved that he's only in a foot boot.
你是加拿大人，我以为你指的是汽车后备箱，所以我真的松了一口气，因为他只穿着一只脚靴。
I forgot I juggled on this episode, Craig.
我忘了我在这一集里耍了花招，克雷格。
Did you, you obviously knew I could juggle, right?
你，你显然知道我会杂耍，对吗？
I really forgot you could juggle.
我真的忘了你还能杂耍。
I mean, I obviously knew at the time because we wrote it in, I guess, or asked you, but that was some good juggling, my friend.
我的意思是，我当时显然知道，因为我们写下了它，我猜，或者问过你，但那是一些很好的杂耍，我的朋友。
I learned to juggle, but I was like five.
我学会了杂耍，但我才五岁。
to definitely a special skill.
绝对是一项特殊技能。
Very skillful, Joe.
非常熟练，乔。
You guys were pulling out all the stuffs.
你们把所有的东西都拿出来了。
This is the thing.
就是这样。
This episode was a fucking circus.
这一集真是他妈的马戏团。
I mean, it was just, no stone was unturned in this episode.
我的意思是，这一集中不遗余力。
It's a delight.
真是令人高兴。
It was a delight to watch this one again.
再次观看这个真是令人高兴。
Do you remember how Jason Seagull would turn things into songs and then he would sing them over and over and over and over again?
你还记得海鸥杰森如何把东西变成歌曲，然后他一遍又一遍地唱吗？
Not just, I'm not talking like being a lawyer, but you're saying Seagull and something new.
不仅仅是，我不是像律师那样说话，而是你说的是海鸥和新的东西。
I'm saying Jason Seagull would take certain lines.
我是说杰森海鸥会采取某些路线。
And this line, a throwaway, most people wouldn't remember it, works for baboons, it's called present.
这句台词，是一次性的，大多数人不会记得它，适用于狒狒，它被称为礼物。
Presenting.
呈现。
Jason wrote like an aria, like an opera.
杰森写得像一首咏叹调，像一部歌剧。
And I can't quite sing it, but he would sing it like, all the time, I mean, during the episode, it carried on, I mean, it went on for a while.
我不太能唱这首歌，但他会一直唱，我的意思是，在这一集里，它继续唱，我的意思是，它持续了一段时间。
I have no memory.
我没有记忆。
I have a strong memory of Jason's operatic version of it, works for baboons, it's called Presenting.
我对杰森的歌剧版本记忆犹新，为狒狒创作，叫做“呈现”。
If we can get him on the show, we should ask her about this because.
如果我们能让他参加节目，我们应该问她这个问题，因为。
Oh my God, piano or just a cappella?
天哪，是钢琴还是无伴奏合唱？
When you be on a cappella, sit in the booth, eat and checks, mix, singing.
当你无伴奏合唱时，坐在包厢里，吃饭、检查、混音、唱歌。
It works for baboon.
它适用于狒狒。
It was something like that.
就是这样的。
It's called presenting something like that.
这就是所谓的呈现类似的东西。
That was the vibe.
这就是氛围。
And then he would try to, he would, and then go, it works for baboon.
然后他会尝试，他会，然后就去，这对狒狒有效。
Like he would really take it up into the tenors.
就像他真的会把它带入男高音一样。
That is only Jason Siegel would do exactly that thing.
只有杰森·西格尔才会这么做。
So we're here.
所以我们就在这里。
We are revisiting that, you know, this is a how long ago was this, was this 17 years ago, this episode or 18?
我们正在重新审视这一点，你知道，这是多久前的事，这是 17 年前的事，这一集还是 18 年前的事？
Alec, check my math.
亚历克，检查一下我的数学。
I was like, yeah, I can't, it was eight.
我当时想，是的，我不能，已经八点了。
So.
所以。
That's crazy.
太疯狂了。
That doesn't seem that long ago, especially the schmuck line, apparently.
这似乎并不是很久以前的事情，尤其是那句蠢话，显然。
That's so you're still right there.
那就是说你还在那里。
Yeah.
是的。
But what is it?
但它是什么？
So here we're on this podcast going back and having these memories, you're actually going back.
所以我们在这个播客中回顾并拥有这些记忆，你实际上是在回去。
Like you are going home again in Scrubs 2.0.
就像你在 Scrubs 2.0 中再次回家一样。
I don't mean to put you back on that press tour and ask you the question.
我并不是想让你重新参加新闻发布会并问你这个问题。
And literally I'm sure everybody has to.
从字面上看，我确信每个人都必须这样做。
But only because we're on a podcast talking about looking back, what type of, what does it feel like?
但这只是因为我们在播客上谈论回顾，什么类型，感觉如何？
What does it feel like?
感觉如何？
Are you right back in and it just feels like, yup, the band's back together again?
你是不是马上回来了，感觉就像是，乐队又重新聚在一起了？
Or do you feel the amount of time since the show went off the air?
或者说你感觉节目停播已经过去了多久吗？
And this feels like a really kind of new experience.
这感觉真的是一种新的体验。
And they're like, where does it feel like?
他们会想，感觉怎么样？
We haven't, we don't know.
我们没有，我们不知道。
We have not done a how much of other reboot.
我们还没有做过多少其他重启。
So tell us what- Will you guys, would you ever do it?
那么请告诉我们——你们会这么做吗？
Or like a movie?
还是像电影一样？
Ah, who knows?
啊，谁知道呢？
You never know?
你永远不知道吗？
No, you know.
不，你知道。
It would be so cool.
那就太酷了。
I have to say I have to recommend it.
我不得不说我必须推荐它。
talking like, I highly recommend it.
说起来，我强烈推荐它。
It has been, I knew it was going to be fun.
确实如此，我知道这会很有趣。
I knew it was going to be great.
我知道这会很棒。
Scrubs was like my favorite job of my life.
实习医生就像我一生中最喜欢的工作。
I grew up on that set, you know, it was eight years of my life.
我是在那个片场长大的，你知道，那是我一生的八年。
And I was, you know, 24 to 32 when we did it.
当我们这么做的时候，我才 24 岁到 32 岁。
And I knew it would be great.
我知道那会很棒。
And I have to say it was actually, I think, better than I thought it was going to be for multiple reasons.
我不得不说，我认为，由于多种原因，它实际上比我想象的要好。
Like, I think it's like, Josh, you were saying earlier, you are on a show and and you know that you're part of something special, I think, and you understand that, but then with the distance and the time in between, I think you kind of digest that even more.
就像，我想，乔什，你之前说过，你在参加一场演出，你知道你是一些特别的事情的一部分，我想，你明白这一点，但随着距离和中间的时间，我想你会更多地消化这一点。
And it's always such a rare combination of things when you love the writing and the part and the people and all of it, and so it was really rare.
当你喜欢写作、角色、人物以及所有这些时，这总是一种罕见的组合，所以它真的很罕见。
And so it was so fun to get to come back to that.
所以回到这个话题真是太有趣了。
And I feel like it was wild, something I hadn't expected is just how fast you fall into it.
我觉得这很疯狂，我没想到你会如此之快地陷入其中。
Like I feel like the first day on a job, on a new set, on a new series, you're finding your way into the character and your meaning.
我感觉就像是第一天上班、在新场景、在新系列中，你正在找到融入角色和意义的方式。
The people in every set is its own ecosystem and its own vibe.
每个群体中的人都有自己的生态系统和自己的氛围。
And so to kind of go right back into one of those where all the factors you already know is such a wild experience?
那么，回到那些你已经知道的所有因素都是如此疯狂的经历之一吗？
Is it a lot of the same crew?
是不是有很多相同的船员？
Is it like, is it the same, is it the same hospital?
是不是一样，是不是一样，是同一个医院吗？
Or is it, is that place still there?
或者说，那个地方还在吗？
No, that was torn down.
不，那是被拆掉了。
That was torn down, I thought so.
那个被拆了，我也是这么想的。
That was far down.
那已经很远了。
You can't go home again fully.
你不能完全回家了。
No, so the craziest thing is that I moved back to Canada and I was like, oh, I love doing, I missed doing comedy and I wanted to do a comedy, but no comedies shoot up here.
不，所以最疯狂的事情是我搬回加拿大，我当时想，哦，我喜欢这样做，我怀念做喜剧，我想做一部喜剧，但这里没有喜剧。
And I just wanted to do a comedy like Scrubs, it felt like Scrubs, but the chutes in Vancouver.
我只是想做一部像《实习医生风云》那样的喜剧，感觉就像《实习医生风云》，但是是在温哥华的降落伞。
And that's what ended up happening.
这就是最终发生的事情。
That's what happened happening.
这就是所发生的事情。
We just shoot it in Vancouver.
我们只是在温哥华拍摄的。
Everything shoots in Vancouver.
一切都在温哥华拍摄。
Yeah, and so they rebuilt, they rebuilt the whole set.
是的，所以他们重建了，他们重建了整个场景。
So we were working in an abandoned hospital.
所以我们在一家废弃的医院工作。
It was an actual functioning hospital for, This is genius for you.
这是一家实际运作的医院，这对你来说是天才。
This is so perfect for you.
这对你来说太完美了。
And after pointing to where their home run is, you get to sleep at home.
指着他们的本垒打在哪里后，你就可以回家睡觉了。
Yeah, my kids, it was crazy.
是的，我的孩子们，这太疯狂了。
My kids came to the set, my daughter is 10, she was 9 when we were shooting it and she would come to the set and plop up behind the monitor at Video Village with all the producers and the director and she'd be wearing the contact and she got a clipboard from props and after the first take, Zach and Dawn, when I come back around behind the monitor, and she has a page of notes for us.
我的孩子们来到片场，我的女儿10岁，我们拍摄时她9岁，她会来到片场，和所有制片人和导演一起坐在Video Village的监视器后面，她会戴着隐形眼镜，她从道具上拿一个剪贴板，在第一次拍摄后，扎克和黎明，当我回到监视器后面时，她给我们写了一页笔记。
She's like, Donald, I love the way you said it, but I just don't think it was kind to tell the patient that he didn't look good, and Zach was like, well, that's a script note.
她说，唐纳德，我喜欢你说话的方式，但我只是认为告诉病人他看起来不太好是件好事，而扎克则说，好吧，那是一个剧本说明。
And so anyway, it was so fun to get to share it, you know, with all of them.
不管怎样，与所有人分享它真是太有趣了。
But yeah, so the first day walking on to this new sound stage is like they rebuilt 19,000 square feet of multiple sets.
但是，是的，所以第一天走进这个新的摄影棚就好像他们重建了 19,000 平方英尺的多个布景。
And, you know, it's identical.
而且，你知道，它是相同的。
Like, it's not even like they got like 75, it's 100% identical.
就像，他们甚至不像 75 那样，而是 100% 相同。
And so that experience is actually hard to kind of put in words of how surreal that felt to step on to that set again.
因此，这种经历实际上很难用语言来形容再次踏上那个场景的超现实感觉。
And then, you know, just how quickly it was like, oh, you're just playing your character.
然后，你知道，很快就感觉，哦，你只是在扮演你的角色。
And I would say the one challenge was figuring out how to bring it into 2026, because there was, as we did the show, and as the years went on, it got more and more broad to the point where like not in a fantasy sequence, but in an actual real time part of the show, there was like a ostrich and a kangal, you know, running around.
我想说，一个挑战是弄清楚如何将其带入 2026 年，因为正如我们制作这部剧一样，随着时间的推移，它变得越来越广泛，以至于不是在奇幻序列中，而是在剧中的实时部分，就像一只鸵鸟和一只袋鼠，你知道，到处乱跑。
And so I think everybody wanted like Bill and Zack and a Seamar showrunner wanted to bring it, you know, back to the first couple of seasons of how grounded it was.
所以我想每个人都想像比尔和扎克以及西马尔的制片人一样想把它带回到前几季的基础上。
And so for us, the challenge was like, how do you, you know, just find that thread, that needle of it not being quite as broad as we did sometimes, but also still feel true to the character.
所以对我们来说，挑战就像是，你知道，如何找到那根线，那根针不像我们有时那样广泛，但仍然感觉对角色很真实。
That was kind of the one kind of thing to figure out, but not it just kind of felt like we were just here.
这是一种需要弄清楚的事情，但不仅仅是感觉我们就在这里。
It's insane how perfectly this fit into your life.
这与你的生活完美契合，真是太疯狂了。
And also it's so cool.
而且它也很酷。
So my daughter Celia is 10.
我女儿西莉亚 10 岁了。
We both have 10-year-old daughters, I guess.
我想我们都有 10 岁的女儿。
And I always feel so, I feel sad that she can't get to know what it was like doing how much money.
我也一直这么觉得，我为她无法了解自己赚了多少钱而感到难过。
My son, Elliot, was on the set.
我的儿子艾略特也在片场。
He would call action, you know, for scenes when he was visiting and like he remembers that and he's he met Pam Friman and would sit next to her and like he knows Josh and like Celia has no idea What that felt like that's such a gift that your ten-year-old daughter Gets to have this glimpse into literally what you were doing before she was born It's that is a very unique thing.
你知道，他会为他来访时的场景调用动作，就像他记得那样，他遇到了帕姆·弗里曼，坐在她旁边，就像他认识乔什，就像西莉亚不知道那是什么感觉，那是一份礼物，让你十岁的女儿能够一睹你在她出生之前所做的事情，这是一件非常独特的事情。
It's also weird.
这也很奇怪。
It's like because we had these long-running shows It's almost like The world's most impressive home movie to get to show your kids like this is your mom in her thirties It's crazy running away from an ostrich and a kangal Yeah, yeah, totally like it's um, it's so cool to your I mean, obviously your son not yet Josh But he will watch them one day all of the how I met your mothers.
这就像因为我们有这些长期播放的节目，这几乎就像世界上最令人印象深刻的家庭电影，向你的孩子们展示这就是你三十多岁的妈妈，逃离鸵鸟和袋鼠真是太疯狂了是的，是的，完全就像它，嗯，这对你来说太酷了我的意思是，显然你的儿子还不是乔什，但有一天他会看他们我是如何认识你母亲的。
Yeah, he's not into it right now It's kind of weird.
是的，他现在不感兴趣，这有点奇怪。
It can't follow it.
它无法跟随它。
It's like, it's not that hard.
就像，这并不难。
My son is super into how I met your mother right now.
我儿子非常喜欢我现在是如何认识你母亲的。
He's watching it all the time, and he's always jumping ahead of where we are on the podcast and then asked me to watch with him.
他一直在看，而且总是跳到我们在播客上的位置，然后让我和他一起看。
I'm like, no, I can't.
我想，不，我不能。
I'm watching it.
我正在看着它。
I'm in time with this.
我正赶上这件事。
And but he's like, well, he's really obsessed with it.
但他就像，嗯，他真的很着迷。
He loves Josh.
他爱乔什。
He listens to the podcast.
他听播客。
He will hear this.
他会听到这个。
So hi, Elliot.
嗨，艾略特。
We're all here talking about you.
我们都在这里谈论你。
And he loves it.
他喜欢它。
And Celia is campaigning to start watching it because she sees her brothers obsessed.
西莉亚正在争取开始观看它，因为她看到她的兄弟们对此很着迷。
and there's the debate of is 10, the right age for this stuff.
还有一个争论是10岁是这个东西的合适年龄。
A precocious 10.
早熟的10.
Yeah, sometimes people tell me.
是的，有时人们会告诉我。
Some, a kid and his mother came to one of my concerts, I think it was in Baltimore, and I met them afterwards and, but they were very big fans of my music, but also how I met your mother.
有些人，一个孩子和他的母亲来听我的一场音乐会，我想是在巴尔的摩，后来我遇见了他们，但他们是我音乐的忠实粉丝，也是我如何认识你母亲的。
And this kid was so young, and I wanted to be like, no, no, no, no.
这个孩子太小了，我想，不，不，不，不。
He can't be white on things.
他不能对事情一视同仁。
I'm not flattered, but please stop this.
我并不受宠若惊，但请停止这种行为。
Yeah.
是的。
Totally.
完全。
Yeah.
是的。
Totally.
完全。
Is there anything, Craig, do you want to run?
克雷格，你有什么想跑的吗？
I just have a couple of other funny things.
我还有一些其他有趣的事情。
Yeah.
是的。
A couple more lightning rounds to close it out.
再用几轮闪电来结束它。
Okay.
好的。
Details from the episode.
剧情细节。
Sarah, the thing where you're getting Abby to hang up the phone and when someone's screaming at her and her just like fear of doing it and you're, but the reveal that it's Barney on the other end.
莎拉，你让艾比挂断电话，当有人对她尖叫时，她就像害怕这样做，而你却发现那头是巴尼。
I'm so forgot that it was Barney.
我差点忘了那是巴尼。
It was so funny.
太有趣了。
It's so funny.
太搞笑了。
That's such a good, how I met your mother, switch her room.
太好了，我怎么认识你妈妈的，换了她的房间。
Yeah, pay attention.
是的，注意。
Keep watching.
继续观察。
This will be awesome now.
现在这会很棒。
She would, she said, you're like a knight, I should call you Sir Ted.
她会，她说，你就像一位骑士，我应该叫你特德爵士。
Like her babbling, kind of nervous talk to him.
就像她喋喋不休，和他说话有点紧张。
It made every line is so funny.
这使得每一句台词都那么有趣。
Yeah, she was great.
是的，她很棒。
That's, that's funny, smart and great.
那就是，这很有趣，很聪明，而且很棒。
It's like incredible when she brings the book into the examining room.
当她把书带进检查室时，感觉真是不可思议。
It says right here from the library of Ted.
上面写着来自特德图书馆。
Ted is so thoroughly vested by Abby and also, like, uncomfortable.
泰德完全被艾比所归属，而且也感到不舒服。
It's so clear that Ted has one of those, like, embossers for his book.
很明显，特德在他的书中有这样一个浮雕。
Yeah.
是的。
And the fact that it was like Marshall's book that we find out later, that was so great.
事实上，这就像我们后来发现的马歇尔的书，这真是太棒了。
Yeah.
是的。
Um, the, uh, I also love, we have this thing, uh, Sarah, where at one point in season one, Marshall says, hold on, I'm going to make some popcorn.
嗯，呃，我也喜欢，我们有这个东西，呃，莎拉，在第一季的某个时刻，马歇尔说，等等，我要做一些爆米花。
And that's the end of the, uh, uh, act.
这就是，呃，呃，表演的结束。
And then he comes back in with fresh popcorn at the start of it.
然后他一开始就带着新鲜的爆米花回来了。
And Craig is like, yeah, we built in a popcorn break.
克雷格说，是的，我们在爆米花休息时间里建了一个。
Like it takes literally time commercial break that was the real time commercial and we do it again in this one.
就像它确实需要时间商业广告一样，这是实时广告，我们在这个广告中再次这样做。
We do it in this episode.
我们在这一集中这样做。
I'm going to pee.
我要去撒尿。
It's the length of a pee.
这是小便的长度。
And then you're back.
然后你就回来了。
Yes.
是的。
Exactly.
确切地。
Like the popcorn.
就像爆米花一样。
Yeah.
是的。
That's so good.
那太好了。
I thought.
我想。
Yeah.
是的。
I love that.
我喜欢那个。
I loved follicular filia.
我喜欢滤泡丝。
And your kind of look coming back when when when I'm laughing and you're that look on your face with some of my staffs, that was fantastic.
当我大笑的时候，你的表情又回来了，你和我的一些员工脸上的表情真是太棒了。
Realizing up, but also like I can get you to.
意识到了，但也像我可以让你做到的那样。
Barney, I liked Barney so much in this episode.
巴尼，我非常喜欢这一集中的巴尼。
In the bracket, he's as gross as he's ever been.
在括号里，他和以前一样恶心。
Yes, that's the next episode.
是的，这是下一集。
But in this episode, we actually really liked Barney when his motivation is not getting laid when it's something else like showing up his friend or winning a bet.
但在这一集中，我们实际上真的很喜欢巴尼，因为他的动机不是为了其他事情，比如向他的朋友露面或赢得赌注。
Like his commitment to victory at all costs is just like astonishing.
他不惜一切代价追求胜利的决心简直令人震惊。
He's been working for years to trick Ted into wearing a mustache.
多年来他一直在努力欺骗特德留胡子。
Sir, also just weird side compliment.
先生，也只是奇怪的侧面恭维。
You have one of the great laughs that seems like a very real laugh when you're acting in a scene and you have to do six takes of it.
当你在一个场景中表演并且你必须拍六次的时候，你会发出一种很棒的笑声，看起来就像是一种非常真实的笑声。
And it's always real, I think it's because you are just a very joyful person, I think it feels like you were accessing like a real laugh every time.
它总是真实的，我认为这是因为你是一个非常快乐的人，我认为你每次都像真正的笑声一样。
So kudos, I don't know what your trick is there, but you don't have to tell us.
所以，荣誉，我不知道你的技巧是什么，但你不必告诉我们。
I'm using a very funny environment, working with a very, very funny group of people.
我正在使用一个非常有趣的环境，与一群非常非常有趣的人一起工作。
So I don't think it was hard for me to access and genuine laughs.
所以我认为获得真正的笑声对我来说并不困难。
Oh my God, of course you turn around compliment your kid anything she was acting.
天哪，你当然会转过身去称赞你的孩子所做的一切。
I was making her laugh.
我正在逗她笑。
I can't laugh on you and make it look real if there's nothing to make me laugh.
如果没有什么能让我笑的话，我就不能嘲笑你，也不能让它看起来很真实。
That was pretty good actually.
其实那已经很不错了。
That was too good.
那太好了。
It's good.
很好。
You are.
你是。
I don't know what you're doing right now, but it's too good.
我不知道你现在在做什么，但这太好了。
It's scary.
太可怕了。
What about when Abby said, love the stash, you look like a young Tom Selleck only a million times handsome.
当艾比说“喜欢这些藏品”时，你看起来像年轻的汤姆·塞立克，只是英俊一百万倍。
She's like, I liked how everyone went and saw Stella it was almost like how everyone goes and sees Arthur but in in their imagination like people actually went to Stella's office Yes, everyone's very invested in his love life to they will make time to go have a dermatology appointment They are very involved, but then Marshall actually gets a mole that he then is like super He did not go for this and then that ends up being what he finds out another really great time joke in this episode Craig is is Marshall knowing what he wants to have in 10 weeks for lunch.
她就像，我喜欢每个人去看斯特拉的方式，这几乎就像每个人去看亚瑟的方式，但在他们的想象中，就像人们实际上去了斯特拉的办公室一样，是的，每个人都非常投入他的爱情生活，他们会抽出时间去进行皮肤科预约，他们非常投入，但马歇尔实际上得到了一颗痣，然后他就像超级他没有这样做，然后这最终成为他在这一集中发现的另一个非常好的笑话，克雷格是马歇尔知道什么他想在 10 周后吃午餐。
Yes, boom, right for dinner and then he offers the shrimp cocktail.
是的，繁荣，正好吃晚饭，然后他提供虾鸡尾酒。
It's so funny.
太搞笑了。
It's the weirdest lunch, too.
这也是最奇怪的午餐。
It's so specific and it would be really weird lunch to have.
它是如此具体，吃午餐真的很奇怪。
Yeah, Sarah, I liked your line the last two minute date.
是的，莎拉，我喜欢你约会最后两分钟的台词。
I had gave me a daughter.
我给了我一个女儿。
Yeah, that was pretty nice.
是的，那真是太好了。
That was so fun.
那真是太有趣了。
Very good.
非常好。
How did you guys come up with Big Stars 13, which is such a perfect song for it, but where did that come from?
你们是怎么想出《Big Stars 13》的，这是一首如此完美的歌曲，但它是从哪里来的呢？
That is a Carter Bay's pitch.
那是卡特贝的球场。
He loved that song.
他喜欢那首歌。
He turned me onto that song and the way that song sort of sits to that whole two-minute date and it has lyrics But the lyrics aren't fighting the dialogue.
他让我想起那首歌，这首歌有点像整个两分钟的约会，它有歌词，但歌词并没有与对话相抗衡。
It's just such a sweet melody It's just it's it's so rare you can just play a song and it's perfect.
这只是如此甜美的旋律，只是它是如此罕见，你只需演奏一首歌就可以了，它是完美的。
There's nothing to edit There's nothing and I don't know what it is about that guy's vocals and the band big star on song 13 If you know that song look it up.
没有什么可编辑的，没有什么，我不知道第 13 首歌中那个家伙的声音和乐队大明星的情况如何。如果你知道那首歌，请查一下。
It's fantastic You can have singing underneath all of this important dialogue and not fight the dialogue That's right.
这太棒了，你可以在所有这些重要的对话下面唱歌，而不是对抗对话，没错。
It's the perfect song.
这是一首完美的歌曲。
It's rare you find a song like that.
很难找到这样的歌曲。
Yeah, but that's it but yeah, I love that sound.
是的，但就是这样，但是是的，我喜欢那个声音。
I had forgotten, but you know what really made me laugh is, oh, Stanford, Wesleyan, oh, did you know so-and-so?
我忘了，但你知道真正让我发笑的是，哦，斯坦福大学，卫斯理学院，哦，你认识某某吗？
No, did you know so-and-so?
不，你认识某某吗？
Like dropping names from college of the same era.
就像从同一时代的大学中删除名字一样。
I loved I almost walked out five times in the movie too.
我很喜欢这部电影，我也有五次差点走出去。
Like the way they're both agreeing on the bit, the yes-ending that's happening between these two people who have chemistry who are in the way, the way you're just committing to the bit right away with Ted, like it just felt, you guys have really good chemistry.
就像他们在这件事上达成一致的方式，在这两个有化学反应但碍事的人之间发生的“是的结局”，就像你马上和泰德一起承诺的方式，就像感觉上一样，你们之间的化学反应非常好。
Like you want to see more of you too, which was of course the plan, although I don't think we told anyone that, but we knew we wanted to do back.
就像你也想见到更多人一样，这当然是计划，虽然我不认为我们告诉过任何人，但我们知道我们想回来。
And we actually, we're trying to make a movie in 15 seconds, which I really like that.
事实上，我们正在尝试在 15 秒内制作一部电影，我真的很喜欢这一点。
15 seconds, that was great.
15秒，太棒了。
That was great.
那很棒。
Well, look, send the great Sarah Chalk.
好吧，看，请发送伟大的莎拉·乔克。
I mean, you're a funny, smart, and great Sarah Chalk.
我的意思是，你是一个有趣、聪明、伟大的莎拉·乔克。
We've taken up too much of your time, I feel.
我觉得我们占用了你太多的时间。
No, thank you guys so much for having me and thank you for having me on all of those episodes.
不，非常感谢你们邀请我，也感谢你们邀请我参加所有这些剧集。
I look back at it as one of the most fun things I've gotten to do in my career.
回想起来，这是我职业生涯中做过的最有趣的事情之一。
It was so fun.
太有趣了。
Every day was such a pleasure on set, and that's a tribute to the environment that you created, and I'm sure that's a constant.
在片场的每一天都是如此愉快，这是对你创造的环境的致敬，我相信这将是一个常数。
It always felt...
总感觉...
Everybody who comes on.
凡是上场的人。
It always felt like a treat every time you were on set.
每次在片场，都感觉像是一种享受。
Like really, I loved our storyline, I loved working with you.
真的，我喜欢我们的故事情节，我喜欢和你一起工作。
We may bug you again in season four to come talk about one of the later episodes.
我们可能会在第四季再次打扰您来谈论后面的一集。
We'll see.
我们拭目以待。
Oh yeah, I would love it.
哦，是的，我会喜欢的。
And then when you guys do your reboot.
然后当你们重新启动时。
I am guilty, please equip me, all sins are forgiven, in New York City.
我有罪，请装备我，所有的罪孽都被宽恕，在纽约。
How We Made Your Mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas, and it's presented and distributed by the Office Ladies Network and Odyssey.
《我们如何造就你的母亲》由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持并执行制作，由 Office Ladies Network 和 Odyssey 出品和发行。
The show is also executive produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey, and the show is produced and edited by me, Alec Lev.
该节目还由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛担任执行制作人，由我亚历克·列夫制作和编辑。
Our co-producer is Doug Matica.
我们的联合制片人是道格·马蒂卡。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves, a point of blue studios, and our Gen Z Masters, our digital content producer, Emily Blumberg, and associate producer, Catherine Grove.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Alex Reeves（blue studio 的一个点），还有我们的 Gen Z Masters、我们的数字内容制作人 Emily Blumberg 和副制作人 Catherine Grove。
Artwork by John Morrow.
约翰·莫罗的艺术作品。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在 Apple 播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论该节目。
It really does help to spread the word.
它确实有助于传播信息。
Our theme song is New York City by our own Josh Radner, with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是我们自己的乔什·拉德纳 (Josh Radner) 创作的《纽约市》，其他音乐由克雷格·托马斯 (Craig Thomas) 和安德鲁·马尤斯基 (Andrew Majuski) 创作。
Special thanks to Sam Theobold and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢 Sam Theobold 和 Elliot Connors。
Go to HowWeMajorMother.com to learn more and click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
请访问 HowWeMajorMother.com 了解更多信息，然后单击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音消息。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's Muse Letters on Substack and check out his music and everything else at JoshRadner.com.
在 Substack 上订阅 Josh Radner 的 Muse Letters，并在 JoshRadner.com 上查看他的音乐和其他所有内容。
Order Craig Thomas' debut novel, that's not how it happened, Wherever Books Are Sold, can read his other published writing at CraigThomasRider.com.
订购克雷格·托马斯的处女作，但事实并非如此，无论书在哪里出售，都可以在 CraigThomasRider.com 上阅读他出版的其他作品。
And you could subscribe to my own dead father's society on sub-step.
你还可以订阅我已故父亲的社团。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise funds for congenital heart disease research, check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
要了解您如何做出改变，这显示了正在进行的为先天性心脏病研究筹集资金的活动，请查看我们网站顶部的“做出改变”选项卡。
will, in fact, dance.
事实上，会跳舞。